foreign
of software development week by simply
learn brings us to the advanced Java
Concepts we hope all the previous
sessions that discuss the data
structures and algorithms C plus plus
and core Java Concepts were really
helpful we also understand that not
everyone made it and we believe in
leaving No Man Behind
so we have linked the videos in the
description box below hope you check all
the previous sessions getting into the
topic the advanced Java covers the
complex parts of exception handling and
we dive deep into the Java Enterprise
Edition Java serverless Java API Java
jdbc and much more
all these segments are proven to be used
in day-to-day programming and play a
vital role in software development
process
so without any further Ado I would like
to hand the session over to our experts
to walk you through the advanced Java
Concepts so we'll start off with
understanding what exactly is
enumeration in Java then we'll continue
with annotations in Java followed by
that we have serialization in Java then
we'll dive into multi-threading in Java
next we have synchronization in Java and
auto boxing in Java later we will
discuss about input and output streams
in Java advancing ahead we have few more
topics that are Java database
connections that is jdbc next we have
generics in Java string handling in Java
and the libraries which are Java Lang
and Java util followed by that we will
discuss the networking in Java next we
have images in Java and concurrency
utilities for the next we have a few
more topics which are regular
expressions in Java non-blocking input
output or nio in Java next we have Java
pins followed by that we will enter into
spring framework next we have the spring
model view controller followed by that
we have spring and rest apis and finally
we will conclude this wonderful session
with a springboard project for a better
learning experience I hope I made myself
clear with the agenda now we'll dive
into the first topic over to our
training experts hello guys this is
vikish and let's get started with enums
or enumerations or enumerated types in
Java so before we go into enums let's
understand why we need it when you were
building when you will be building the
Java applications you will face
scenarios where you will have to Define
some variables which will remain
constant forever for example months of
the year they are not going to change
they are always going to be 12 months in
an year similarly let's say name of
flowers they are not going to change a
Lotus will be a Lotus forever similarly
the name of the seasons will always
remain same the season of summer or
winter will always be called summer or
winter they will not be changed the
meaning of those variables will never be
overwritten or will never be changed so
you can think of them as constants but
they are not the constants which your
programs May mutate or your programs May
interpret differently they will be
interpreted by multiple applications
multiple components multiple consumers
in exactly the same way similarly if you
take the example of time zones they are
fixed they work with the GMT with
respect to the GMT time zone and they
will always remain like that so if you
have if you whenever you have a
situation where you have to Define such
constructs or such constants always
think of enum types or numerated types
enum is basically a language construct
and you can use this language construct
to Define type safe variables when we
say type safe variables what we mean is
that these variables are not integer or
string they are of in types that's the
reason Java created a completely new
data type which is called the enum type
they are by default constant so you
cannot change them that's their property
and the way you define enums is like
this you say public enum so instead of
the keyword class you use the keyword
enum and then you define the name of the
enum the name of the enum type and then
you define the possible values just
simply separating them by a comma so for
example days of the week is again a
constant thing there will always be 7
Days of the Week irrespective of what
you do on this planet so that's why you
can declare an enum for the day and you
can define those as as the values you
also notice that the values are caps by
default and yes that is how you define
the enums
let's have a look at a more interesting
example of the enums in the IDE now so
if I switch to the IDE I have created a
class called color not a class button
enum type called color and this enum
type color is basically holding all the
different color types their value is
basically like all the video colors for
example so I've defined three colors
here which are red green and blue so you
see I've defined them as caps they
automatically become bold you don't have
to bold them but you see an interesting
thing a difference here that there is
another value in the brackets here this
was not there when we looked at this
example of day there is no value inside
each of the enum types but I have
defined the value of the enum types and
that is optional there will be use cases
where you want to Define some enum
constants where the name of the enum
type is a constant which is a
placeholder but it will have an internal
value which may be more practical for
your application so this is what your
consumers see and this is what is used
whenever you call Red inside your
application is just for Simplicity there
would be there might be use cases where
you use some abbreviations and their
full forms for example if you want to
use here an abbreviation of let's say
who
and inside this you can Define the value
as world
Health Organization so this is just a
toy example I'm giving you where you
will have use cases where you want to
define a constant but you want to Define
an internal value of it which is to be
read by your application elsewhere but
everybody who wants to consume this enum
can just use this particular keyword and
if they want to get the value they can
get the value as well
so this is the use case where you might
need to Define values of your enum types
as well but whenever you have to do that
if you want to fetch the value of an
enum type you have to write some extra
code which is written here if you are
not defining the value of your enum
types your enum can be as simple as this
you don't need to Define anything else
apart from just defining the constant of
the enum types I'm I'm giving a more
complex use case so that it covers both
of the things of using just the
constants and also using the values so
if you just want to read the constant
you can just say color dot red or color
dot green or color dot blue in different
classes and you will be able to refer to
the enum types or use the enum types but
if you want to refer to the value of the
enum type then probably you need to call
this method called get value so whenever
you define a value what you would do is
you will Define a private member
variable inside the enum which is
defined here you can name it anything if
you want
you define a Constructor where you set
this particular value and then you
define a getter so whenever some
consumer application wants to refer to
the value of your enum type they can
call this get Value method to get that
so this is the enum now let's see how we
can use this enum for using this enum I
have this main class where I have a
public static void main method and you
can simply fetch the enum types by
writing the code like this just write
the enum type holder and then type the
enum type so let me show you how this is
done if you just put a dot here you will
get all the enum type options so I've
defined three enum types red green and
blue and I get all the options so
whatever option I want to choose I can
just select here and I can store this
inside an enum variable
so if you want to just refer to the name
of the enum so this C1 is holding color
dot red or red so if you want to refer
to this just this red then you can call
the dot name method on the C1 variable
so if you say C1 dot name it is going to
put or print the red in caps and if you
want to fetch the value inside the red
remember the value is red in in small
caps so if you want to refer to the or
if you want to fetch the value of the
red then you call the get Value method
which we have defined here
so that's what we are doing here in this
first two Swiss outs where we are
printing the red enum name and then
printing the redinum value
now you can also iterate over all the
enum types and for that you need to call
the dot values method on the Elam so you
can just say color dot values which is
going to iterate over all the enum types
and you are just storing each of the
enum type in this color placeholder then
you can either call get value to get the
actual value of that enum type or you
can call the name to just print the name
of the enum as well both of the options
are available so let's just put it back
to get value and let's run this code so
if I run this application I get some
output here which looks like this first
Swiss out says red enum name is red in
caps because we are calling the name
method second says red enum value which
prints red in small because we are
calling the get Value method and then we
are iterating over all the enums so I
had three enum variables here red green
and blue and I'm going to iterate over
all of them one by one here printing
their value and not the enum constants
so that's why you see the red green and
blue here in small but if you just want
to print the enum constants themselves
and not their values then you change
this to dot name and then all the enum
constants will be printed here so this
is how you can create enums and use
enums for the constants which are never
going to change in your application
let's get started with annotations in
Java now annotations is a bit Advanced
concept so let's understand why we need
it there would be some cases in your pro
in your application where you need to
provide some metadata information to the
Java compiler now this sounds a bit
complicated but it's much simpler than
that because you might not want to code
everything with lot of lines of code
rather you want to give some smart
instructions to the Java compiler so
that they understand what to do we have
already seen some of the annotations but
the basic idea of annotations is to
provide some shorthand metadata
information about the program to the
Java compiler generally annotations will
not have any direct effect on the
operation of the code they annotate but
they provide additional logic to the
code that's the idea with annotation
remember they are shorthand metadata the
main use is providing information to the
compiler or providing some compile time
or deployment time processing or also
providing some instructions for runtime
processing we have already seen some of
the annotations if you remember when we
were dealing with inheritance we had
this at the rate override over the
methods right this at the rate override
is an annotation this annotation if you
if I if I show you what I'm talking
about if I take you back to one of the
inheritance example or the method
overriding examples and if I open the
mountain bike class here mountain bike
extends bicycle you will see this
override annotation this is an
annotation an annotation always starts
with at the rate in Java and The
annotation name is overwrite now this
override is just a shorthand to tell the
compiler that hey I am overriding this
method from the base class that's what
this annotation does if you remove The
annotation in some cases the Java
compiler might not understand what to do
and the Java compiler has to do some
extra processing to figure out that this
method is actually being overridden but
if you put this at override here then
the Java compiler prehand will know that
this is coming from the base class so
you save some of the compiler processing
time as well by using The annotation
it's a shorthand providing instructions
to the compiler you see exactly what I'm
talking about so this is one of the
annotations which we have used but we
will look at some of the other more
generic annotations and we will also see
how we can build our own custom
annotation in Java you might have also
seen some other annotations like for
example you can put add great suppressor
warning annotation which is a very
popular annotation to suppress any kind
of yellow warnings in your code
generally we do not recommend doing that
but if you have a use case then you can
use at the red suppress annotation as
well there are some other annotations as
well like at the rate author if you want
to put your name as the author of a
particular piece of code then you can
add this metadata so that whenever
somebody he looks at even the
documentation of your code your name
will be shown there as the author so
that's the idea with annotations so
let's see how you can build your own
custom annotation whenever you have to
do that there are multiple ways to doing
that and the first type of annotation we
are going to have a look at is called
marker annotation a marker annotation is
just an empty annotation without having
any metadata logic at all you can see it
is I have defined an annotation here I
will talk about what is all this means
but inside the block there is no code
here and this is how you define in
marker annotation marker annotation is
just to provide very high level
instructions to the compiler and the way
you will write your custom annotation is
you will put an access modifier keyword
like public then you will write add the
rate interface this is the keyword which
you have to use whenever you are trying
to create your custom annotation marker
or no marker doesn't matter whenever you
define your annotation you have to use
at the rate interface once you do that
then you provide a name for your
annotation which can be anything but
still not complete we need to also
provide more instructions to the
compiler or the runtime processor to
tell them when to execute this
annotation and what The annotation type
is going to be applied upon so at first
you specify when this annotation is
going to be active or executed or
evaluated so here you can say add the
rate retention which is another
annotation so you say at direct
retention and then you say retention
policy dot whatever you want to write as
you can write it as runtime or you can
write it as Source if you write it as
Source then it is going to be applied at
compile time and if you select it as
runtime then The annotation is going to
be processed at runtime so this is the
first thing which you need to provide
the second thing which you need to
provide is where this annotation is
going to be applied whether you want
this annotation to be applied to a class
or to a method or to a member variable
or to any other type and that's what you
define in the at the rate target
annotation you specify the target get
audience for this particular annotation
and here inside the element type you
will get multiple options you can apply
this annotation to a Constructor to a
field local variable method module
package record component type Etc so
here I'm going to use type which means
it can be applied to a class or a
generic element type which generally
means Class Type and that's all you can
Define your marker annotation like this
but generally these marker iterations
does not have any logic so you will not
get much value out of it until you have
very special cases but if you have a
case where you want to also run some
business logic or provide some metadata
logic to the compiler while defining The
annotation then you can Define your
annotation like this so I've created one
more annotation here which called which
is called my custom annotation again the
target audience for this is Method so
this annotation can only and only be
applied to methods if you try to apply
this annotation to a class you will get
an error the retention policy is runtime
it means it is going to be processed at
runtime and after declared a method here
which is called int value so this is how
you will declare your annotation now
let's see how you how do you use this
annotation so I have a class called as
my class here and if you look at this
structure of the my class we create the
class and then I create a method which
is named as say hello and I am applying
this annotation on this particular
method remember the target audience of
this particular annotation was method so
it only be applied on method if I try to
put this on the Class Type here then I
get an error here it says The annotation
my custom annotation is disallowed at
this location because the type specified
is of type method so the compiler will
not allow you to use this at an illegal
place so you write any method and you
apply your annotation but you provide a
value to the method the int Value method
is going to consume this value and
inside the method you can write any
other logic so let's see how this pans
out I create a public static voidment
method and I create an object of my
class so my class H equal to new my
class and after that I'm saying H dot
get class dot get method I'm basically
calling the method by using reflection
API you can also call the method
directly if you want but this is how you
need to call it if you want to use The
annotation property value if you want to
fetch the value of The annotation so
this is just an example of me showing
you how you fetch The annotation so we
created an object and then we say get
class which is going to return my class
type and then get method is going to
return the method type which has the
name say hello so this is a way to fetch
a method name or a method type from a
class using Java's reflection API which
is an advanced API you might not need to
use it but for the sake of demo I'm
using this so we fetch the class and we
fetch the method it is going to search
the class for a method name say hello if
it finds the method it is going to
return the method in this variable and
then you can call method Val which was
this variable dot get annotation give me
any annotation which is applied on this
particular method and you supply The
annotation class type as well once you
do that you get uh my custom annotation
reference type and then if you call the
Value method on this you will get this
value as 10. so this is a way where you
can apply an annotation and you can
actually see the effect of The
annotation you might not always want to
do this because like I said these are
metadata instructions to the compiler
but if you have a need to actually see
what your annotation is doing you can
use the getclass.get method to First
fetch the method store it into a method
type and then call get annotation
supplying the exact annotation Class
Type and then you can call the exact
method which is defined in your
annotation here I've defined it as value
so I'm just calling the Value method so
if I run this particular example I get
the value as 10 so I'm able to see or
fetch the exact value which my
annotation metadata is holding at the
runtime and this is the power of
annotation there are very powerful
concept and there are very Advanced
concept they would be very rare
scenarios in your application where you
need to create your custom annotations
generally you will be better off will
with your with your predefined
annotations which are provided in Java
like at the rate override at the red
author at the rate suppress warning Etc
let's get started with serialization in
Java now before we go further let's
understand why we need the concept of
serialization when you will be building
the Enterprise grade applications in in
different organizations you will often
have a use case or a need to send an
object from one application to other
application which is deployed on some
other machine so if you have a network
of computers or if you have a lot of
different uh complex setup where you
need you have a producer application and
you have a consumer application producer
application produces the object and and
then this object gets traveled over the
network lines over the network wires and
reaches at the consumer application and
how does the consumer application
receive the object and how does the
producer application sense the object
because when the data travels over the
network lines it will be all bytes so
how do you convert a Java object into
bytes send it over Network and then the
consumer application has to again
convert that bytes back to an object
representation and then store that or
use that inside its application so you
need to do this whole conversion right
so the process of converting an object
to a byte so that it can be sent over a
network is called serialization and the
process of converting back the byte from
the byte from the network to a Java
object is called deserialization so
generally you you may have a use case
where you see realize an object create a
binary representation of it send it over
the network and that's where the Java
serialization concept kicks in whenever
whenever you have to do this in Java you
will be using the serializable interface
so you need to extend your objects from
this serializable interface so that
those objects themselves becomes
serializable you need to tell Java that
this object is able to serialize itself
and deserialize itself and the way you
will tell Java is by letting that object
implementing the serializable interface
let's have a look at an example for of
this serialization and deserialization
to understand this concept better so
here again I have used the same student
class where it has the name age and
address so you can see I have created a
student class but the student class
implements serializable this is
something which we have to add to your
class second thing the moment you do
that all the modern day ideas like
eclipse or IntelliJ will ask you to add
a Serial version Universal ID to this
particular class this is added so that
Java can uniquely identify your object
once it is serialized and deserialized
and it will also keep a versioning track
of it right because when you serialize
the object what happens if somebody hops
over the network line and change the
representation of your object and the
consumer application will get a
completely different object copy now so
this is Java's way to make sure that the
same version which the producer
application is producing is received by
the consumer application so it's also
sort of a security feature it basically
whenever you do an update onto the
object it is going to increment this
serial version uid by one so when you
create the object first time and you
serialize it for for the very first time
the value is going to be set as default
1 and as you mutate the object again and
again before deserializing it the count
will just keep on increasing so that's
how you keep a track of the state of the
object which is being serialized by
adding this long serial version uid you
can also specify your own value if you
want to by default Java initializes a
value of 1 and this is a long type
variable so that is the only new thing
which is happening the moment you do
Implement serializable after that I have
the same Fields here I have the
Constructor and the Setters and the
Getters and I also have a two string
method just to print the object nicely
where I print the name the age and the
address so let's look at the main class
and where we use the student object we
serialize this object and then we
deserialize this object so what is
happening here is I create a class I
create the main method and I create a
student object this is something which
we have already seen then I want to
store the state of this object when when
you serialize this object this object
has to be either sent to a network but
since I'm running this demo on the same
machine what I will do that I will
serialize this object onto my local
files system it's the same thing right
you can put it somewhere and then fetch
it from there so either you can send it
over the network or you can put it on a
file system so I create the object and
then I need to store this into a file so
far I have not covered the file handling
operations so we will not go deeper into
the file handling classes here but I
will just explain you the reasoning for
it and when we'll do the file handling
session there I will go in detail about
the file handling classes so I specify a
file name via the serialized
representation of my student object is
going to be stored and this is the
location where I'm supposed to store
this then I create two different classes
which is for writing to the file and
then creating an object for it so that's
what I'm doing here we can ignore this
particular part where I'm just supplying
the file name and we can focus on this
part this line where I'm saying write
the object the student object to this
particular file that's what I'm doing
here in this particular in this three
lines of code that I'm writing the
student object to the file so when Java
has to write this object to the file it
is automatically going to serialize it
that's the only way Java can write an
object to the file so you see realize
the object and then you print that
message that the object has been
serialized again you can ignore this
part as well like I said we will not
focus on this but what we technically
did is we just wrote we just wrote the
object to a file by serializing it then
I try to deserialize it so I load the
file load this same file into the Java
jvm and then I read the object and the
way I read the object is by using this
object input stream class I Supply the
file that read this particular file and
then I call the read object method which
is going to return an object a general
object when you call the read object
method the read object method does not
know that it is a student type object so
you so you need to explicitly cast this
to the student type so that you can
store this as a student object object if
you do not cast this you will get an
error because like I said read object
does not know anything about the student
class so what does what does this mean
is that when you serialize an object the
Class Type information is lost you
cannot store the Class Type information
when you serialize an object because the
moment you call this right object method
from the object output stream class so
you created this object output stream
class you supply the file output
location and you call the right object
the moment you call the right object
it's just any Java object for the this
Java program the signature of the
student class is lost it does not know
that it's a student class anymore once
it has been once it is being serialized
similarly when you deserialize it the
serialization API has no idea about what
student class is and what student object
is so you need to tell the read object
method explicitly that hey you are
reading an object of the student type
and that's how this line Works once you
explicitly provide the casting operation
once you have casted it we try to print
the same deserialized object to see if
all the state which we stored in the
object is still persisted there or not
when we deserialize it so our major
focus in this particular class is this
object output stream classes and the
right object method these are the two
most important statements which you need
to take care of the file output stream
is basically a file location what is an
output stream we will talk about that
later but the whenever you need to
serialize you need to use this
particular class called object output
stream so that's all I'm doing here I'm
serializing the object with this these
values and then I will deserialize and I
will again print the object to see if
these values are still there or not so
let's run this application so when I run
this application let's start from here
first this out gets called which says
object has been serialized so you see
object has been serialized and what I
serialized was the student object which
had the value of name as John age as 25
and the address as 23 East California
and that's what gets printed here then
this whole block gets completed this
whole try block gets completed it's a
standard try catch block you see I have
also added the i o exception you need to
do that because these file operations
will force you to catch or throw the io
exception which is a checked exception
that's why it will force you to do that
then we move to the deserialization
block where we create an object of the
object input stream class and then we
call the read object we cast it to the
student type and then we print the
object so when I print this object this
line gets printed object has been
deserialized and then I can see that the
exact same state is still there the name
which I set in the object is still there
after being after being deserialized the
age and the address is exact intact so
this is how we you can serialize an
object send it anywhere you want and
then the consumer application need to
read the object and cast it back to the
student type and they will be able to
see the exact same state which you saved
in the object just before serializing it
what if you have a use case where you do
you have a property in a in a student
class or in your object but you do not
want that to be serialized that's also a
use case where you may have 50 different
properties inside the student class and
one of the property is something which
you do not want to serialize because you
do not want the consumer application to
see that value if you ever had that
scenario use the transient variable so
transient is again a keyword and the
moment you put this keyword in front of
a member variable that variable becomes
transient the use case of transient
variable is that if you do not want this
x to be serialized and deserialized then
you put the transient keyword in front
of it the normal member variables will
automatically get serialized and
deserialized when the object is
serialized and deserialized but if you
have a use case where you do not want a
particular member variable to be
serialized or deserialized put transient
in front of it and then have the Getters
and Setters for this x variable and
let's use this and see if this actually
gets serialized or not so I created the
student object and let me call student
dot set X and let's put a value to X
let's say 10. so I have set the value of
x is 10 and X is our transient variable
and then I am serializing the whole
object here and then I'm deserializing
the object and let's see if I'm able to
fetch the value of x after deserializing
the student object so I'm calling the
system.out.println and the D serialized
value of x is object Dot get X let's see
if I'm able to see the value of x or not
so let's run this application again so
this is exactly the same as before this
is also exactly the same as before but I
see the value of x is 0. remember I set
the value as 10 before serializing it
but I don't see the value 10 anymore
when I deserialize the object because it
was transient if you remove transient
from it then you will be able to
transfer or travel this value of 10
between serialization and
deserialization so if I just remove this
here don't change anything at all and I
just rerun the application this time
when I deserialize the object the value
of x as 10 is still present there even
after deserialization so this is how you
can use the transient variables if you
want to not have that object serialized
or deserialized when you're doing the
serialization let's get started with
concurrency and threads the reason I
want to talk about concrete and see
because once we understand about the
concurrency it will become much more
simpler to talk about threats and the
idea behind concurrency is very simple
and plain and that idea is that as a
developer when you write a program you
would expect the machine or the computer
to run multiple tasks in parallel for
example right now I'm recording this
video on on a particular laptop which is
regarding my voice which is also
recording the screen which is also
running the Eclipse IDE and also running
a Chrome browser it is also have it also
have opened multiple background
applications so there are a lot of tasks
running in parallel at the same time and
that's the idea about concurrency now
how do we work with concurrency in Java
is with the help of processes and
threads so these are the two basic units
of execution when we talk about
concurrent programming in Java and when
we talk about processes you can think of
a process as basically an execution
environment or I should call it as a
stand Standalone execution environment
think of a logical box which is
completely cut out from everything and
it has its own environment for example
again the recording software is running
in its own execution environment and
when we talk about process process
generally has an everything or a private
set of all the runtime resources it
needs and the memory space it needs now
this another concept or another
construct which is very important is
threads so threads are also sometimes
called lightweight processes and
basically when we talk about threads
it's a thread also has an execution
environment but creating a new thread
requires a lot less resources than
creating a new process and you can also
think of threads as a mini version of a
process because a process can have
multiple threads remember that statement
that a process can have multiple threads
threads always exist within a process
and whenever you start a process there
will be at least one thread attached to
it and each thread is basically a task
for example the voice recording can be a
process and inside that the mic
recording expression or the mic
recording or task can be run by a
particular thread let's take another
example that when you play games let's
say you are playing a racing game so
when you play the racing game there are
multiple things happening at once you
see the current speed of your car or
bike on the screen you also see your
leaderboard position what ranking you
have in the race currently you also see
some other kind of features like players
health or the car's health or the fuel
consumption available and lots of other
stuff the graphics the motorcycle the
other com other competitors bikes and
their speeds and their distance to you
as well so if you see all of this are
running are different threads there's a
different thread to show your current
speed there's a different thread to show
the current leaderboard position there's
a different thread to show the fuel
indicate
Etc everything is running in a different
thread so all of these threads need to
run at the same time in your program for
a complete immersive user experience and
that's what we mean when we say
multi-threading that we want multiple
threads to run at the same time to
create a better experience in the
application so that's the basically the
theoretical part of it please do read
about more about how threads work and
how processes work and there's a lot
more documentation available in the Java
docs as well when we talk about threads
but I will keep the theoretical part of
this particular point and now we will
move to an eclipse example to see how we
can create threads so with that let's
move to the Eclipse IDE and here I have
a demo prepared basically so what I have
here is a Threading demo class which has
a public static white main method and it
has a simple for Loop and inside the for
loop I see this strange code here where
I am initializing two threads and
starting them so so that's all I'm doing
here but let's see how this thread one
and thread 2 class have been written and
why do I see two different ways of
initializing them let's go deeper into
this now so let's see how thread one can
be created so first of all you can
create a thread by just creating a
simple class but make sure that you
extend it with the pre-built thread
class this thread class is from coming
from java so from the jdk basically so
the moment you extend your normal class
from the thread class then you will have
to override the run method so if I show
you the thread class here this is the
thread class
implementation available inside the jdk
and this is the class which is getting
called when you are extending is from
the thread class and this thread class
will ask you to override a run method
here the override annotation is missing
so let me just add this for better
understanding so you need to override
the run method and this is something
which you need to do so that you can
specify what happens when you run the
thread so this run method will be called
whenever the thread is running at this
particular point I would also like to
tell you that there are different states
in the thread so there is a thread which
says thread is ready then there is a
state which is which Say thread is
running there is also a state where the
thread is waiting for an i o input from
the user from the console or the command
line there can also be a state which
says dead where the thread has completed
its task and it's not working there can
also be a state which is called Sleep
state where the thread is paused so
there are different states of the thread
and in this example we are going to
focus primarily on three states which is
the ready State and the running State
and the completed state so when you call
the run method the thread state is going
to change to running and whatever code
you write inside this particular run
method will be the logic which this
particular thread is supposed to execute
here I am just putting a dummy logic
where I'm just printing assist out but
definitely if you try to create your
threads this will contain your actual
business Logic for example that fuel
indicator code or for the leaderboard
position code will go inside this run
method and then I'm catching an
exception if there's an exception but
obviously there will not be an exception
coming in because I have nothing here
literally so that's what we are we are
doing when we are creating This Thread
one class and let's come back to the
threading demo now so to initialize a
thread or initialize might not be right
word to run a thread the first thing
which you need to do is to initialize
the class containing the run method so I
would avoid calling this class as thread
because technically this is just a class
so you initial so you basically create
an object of the thread just like you
create the object of any other class
there is nothing new here right so we
just say new thread one and then we call
T1 dot start now if You observe
carefully there is no star method here
we just had a run method but this code
is still compiling fine and I'm calling
the start method here because the start
method is the internal method of the
thread class which in turn is going to
call the run method so you are never
going to invoke the run method directly
you just need to start the thread which
is going to change the state of the
thread from ready to running so the
start method has the responsibility of
changing the state to running and the
way the start method is going to do that
is by calling the run method internally
inside the jdk itself from developer
perspective we just need to call the
start method and that's it the thread
will start running and whatever is
present in the run method will get
executed so that's the way to start the
thread second thing I have one more
thread created here which is the thread
2 class so in this case when I create a
thread 2 class I am not extending it
from the thread class rather I am
implementing the runnable interface here
here so this is a different interface
available which is a functional
interface which means it will have just
one method which is the run method but
the interesting thing is that here when
I created thread one I said extends
thread but here when I'm creating the
second thread I'm not using extends
thread but I am using implements
runnable let's understand why do we do
that first of all the reason Java
provides two different ways of creating
threads is because there might be a use
case that you need to extend your thread
to class from some of your custom Java
class remember Java does not support
multiple inheritance so at a time you
can only extend this class from one
class so what if there was no runnable
interface and you need to extend This
Thread to from student class let's say
so you need to do class thread to
extends student for example the student
is not present here but let's assume it
is so you do this and then you also have
to extend it from thread now Java
doesn't support multi people inheritance
and this will not work so what would you
do if you have to also create it as a
thread but also extend it from some of
your parent class you will not be able
to do that and that's the reason Java
provides the implements runnable because
then you can extend it from any of your
super class of your interest and at the
same time also Implement implement it
with runnable interface so that you can
treat this class as a thread so that's
the reason Java provides two different
ways of creating threads remember that
it's a very important concept and once
you implement runnable again it will ask
you to override the run method so I will
just put override annotation here so
once you override the run method again
you can write whatever logic you want
this particular thread to execute inside
the Run block coming back to the main
class so when you are extending from
thread the initializing initialization
is very simple where you create the
object and you call the start method on
the object but if you are creating a
thread by implementing the run enable
interface the initialization of the
thread is a bit different and it's
different in this particular part on the
left hand side you still say thread T2
remember you are saying thread and not
thread two this is a this is the Java
thread class this is the jdk thread
class not your own third class so you
say thread T2 then you say new thread
and inside the new thread you provide
your own class type thread 2 was your
own class type so you specified your own
custom third class here inside the new
thread Constructor This Thread class is
the jdk class if you click on this you
will see this is from the jdk class so
that's the difference extending thread
simple initialization implementing
runnable interface do the initialization
like this and after that you call the
Sim the similarly the start method which
is in turn going to call the run method
so that was how you create threads
differently and now let's run this
program to understand how the output
looks like when we run these threads in
Loops remember I am initializing 10
instances of each of these threads so in
total there would be 20 output lines so
if I go to run as Java application I see
this output here so let's observe this
output for once so thread one thread 2
is running in sequence in the first time
but then you see thread one is running
twice and then thread 2 is running twice
then again you see a good sequence but
again thread 2 has run twice here again
thread one has run twice if I go further
down thread one runs once then again
thread 2 runs twice thread one runs once
thread two runs once so there is no
particular order here though based on
the code which we have written we should
expect thread one is running from here
and then thread 2 is running output from
here in a sequential fashion but we
don't see the sequential fashion here
and this is the power of concurrency
this is because threads never run in
sequence they run in parallel and which
thread will execute first you can't
really predict that so it's so be very
careful when you whenever you're writing
multi-threading code because you cannot
predict the sequence of execution
because threads are going to run
whenever they find the idle CPU so the
key is the idle CPU whenever a thread
finds an idle CPU it is going to occupy
that CPU and going to run its own
execution and the moment its execution
finishes the other thread will jump in
and take up and take a piece of the CPU
so whichever thread gets the idle piece
of the CPU is going to execute and that
is the reason you see this randomized
output the next time you're going to run
you will see a different random order so
so this time you see thread one ran four
times you did not see this in the
previous execution if you run it again
you will see again a different output
this time the thread one ran price so
every time you will run this you will
see a different sequence there is no
guarantee of order because the threads
are running in parallel and they are
running whenever they get the idle CPU
that's the bottom line so this is is how
we are going to create threads and
remember you cannot guarantee the
sequence of the execution so write your
code accordingly and use the threads for
independently running parallel threads
which do not depend upon each other
let's get started with thread
synchronization in Java so in the
previous example we saw that when we
execute threads then we can't guarantee
the sequence but it's actually
technically not a problem in the example
which we had looked at before but it can
become a bigger problem when two threads
are trying to access the same object
remember object has properties and state
so what if the first thread modified the
object State and the second thread is
reading the state of the object the
second thread is expecting the original
state but while it was trying to read it
the other thread modified it state so
you can see this become a this can
become a big problem for example if you
are working with a banking system and if
there are two persons X accessing the
same account at the same time one is
depositing the money and one is
withdrawing the money from the account
and if the total balance is thousand and
if both of them deposit 500 and withdraw
500 at the same time then who sees what
and if these are two if these are
handled by two different threads then we
can't guarantee if somebody sees a 1500
as the total sum or somebody sees a 500
as a total sum or there can be a
scenario where somebody sees 0 as the
total sum so it there so the application
can turn into really weird scenarios if
two threads are trying to change the
state of a particular object at the same
time and Java provides a solution of it
with the concept of intrinsic logs and
synchronizations so the idea is that
when a thread tries to work on a
particular object it basically takes a
lock on that particular object we also
call this as an intrinsic lock or
monitor lock so it takes a lock on the
object and it means that that particular
object becomes completely inaccessible
to other threads in the system at that
particular time so the moment you put
synchronization or you put lock on a
particular object only the thread which
has taken the lock will be able to
access the object and other threads will
be forbidden from accessing the object
so that's the idea behind intrinsic
locks and synchronization so that was
about the brief theory of it now let's
have a look at a practical example so I
have prepared another example for it so
here I have again created two threads
but these two threads it's the pretty
much the same threads which we covered
in the previous session named as thread
one and thread two one is extending
thread class and other is implementing
runnable but that's the that's same but
the interesting part is this both of
them have a reference to a class called
math utils if you see thread one also
has the reference and thread 2 also has
the reference and what the math utensils
is doing here is basically you supply a
number and it prints them multiples of
it till five so for example if you
supply two you will get the output 2 4 6
8 10 if you supply three you will get
the multiple of 3 up to 3 times 5 so 3 6
9 12 15. if you supply 4 you will get
the outputs of the in the multiples of 4
till 20. so whatever number you will
supply you will get the next five
multiples of that particular number
that's what this class is doing and
another thing which interesting thing
which I've done here is this
thread.sleep which means that when you
run this Loop where you are printing the
multiples till 5 of that number every
time you do the first multiplication
then you sleep for 400 millisecond and
when I say sleep it basically means the
current thread is going to pause its
execution for 400 millisecond and it is
going to leave the CPU idle and if there
is another thread running currently in
the system that thread will get the
share of the CPU for that 400
millisecond and once the 400
milliseconds is finished then the thread
is going to wake up and it is again
going to hunt for the idle CPU to pick
up and start doing its execution so that
thread.sleep happens for 400
milliseconds at every step of this
iteration in this for Loop so thread one
is going to use this particular method
of this particular class and it is going
to ask the class to print the multiples
of 2 and thread 2 is also going to
access the reference of the class and
access the get multiples method but this
thread asks to print the multiple of
three so thread one asks for printing
the multiples of 2 up to 2 times 5 and
thread 2 wants to print the output to
multiple sub 3 up to 3 times 5 so that's
the basic scenario two threads accessing
the same object supplying different
values and expecting the output so if I
run this demo as is without any change
here I'm just initializing the
mathematics class initializing two
threads and then calling the start only
once so if I run this particular program
I see get I see this strange output that
even when I said T1 dot start first so
T1 was holding the multiple of two
remember but I still get three first
then two then four six so multiples of
two gets executed here but then the
other thread takes the CPU and it starts
running its own multiples outputs and
you see nine printing first and then six
gets printed then 12 then 8 then 15 and
then 10 at very last so the output looks
very random it would have been nicer if
if I could have seen two four six at 10
once and then 3 6 9 12 15 once if I see
them in different sections in different
sequences that would have been so nice
because then I know which thread is
running when and when that particular
thread is working on the object so I'm
just trying to replicate the same
scenario where two threads are accessing
the same object at the same time but
they are executing the object randomly
they are changing the state of the
object randomly here so how do we fix
this to fix this we can put so we have
this get multiples method which is the
bone of contention here this is the
method which is being randomly accessed
so what I can do here that I can put
synchronized keyword in front of the
method so once you put the synchronized
keyword in front of the method which is
being accessed by multiple threads at
the same time this method this whole
method gets synchronized now what this
means that one thread will be execute
this method at once there will never be
a scenario where two threads are
simultaneously executing this get
multiples method or even getting a hold
of this get multiples method at the same
time there would be only one thread at a
time executing this method so if I put
the synchronized here and if I rerun
this example you see I get a more
streamlined output if you notice
everything is one running like clockwork
where first the thread one gets executed
so I get 2 4 6 8 10 really well printed
and then the second thread starts which
says 3 6 9 12 15. the reason I get this
output is because when I did T1 dot
start it immediately went to execute the
get multiples method but it saw
synchronized there so it took a lock on
the method and even when the t2 dot
start might have got executed maybe
milliseconds after that or nanoseconds
after that it still could not get hold
of the get multiples method because
thread one occupied this particular
method it took a lock on this particular
method due to the synchronized keyword
so that's the power of synchronized
keyword that you can take a lock on a
particular method if you put it in front
of the method now there can be scenarios
that you do not want to lock the whole
method you still want two different
threads to access the method but there
can be very few lines of code inside the
method which is the which is thread
sensitive code now how do you spot
thread sensitive code there is no magic
bullet there is no Silver Bullet for it
and it comes with experience so you need
to have that experience to know which is
the thread sensitive code which can
create problems if two threads run that
code at the same time so the moment you
have spotted that code and if you don't
want to lock the whole method you can
lock the exact lines of Code by putting
the synchronized block so if I remove
this and I enable this particular part
so what I am doing that I know that this
is the code which is exactly causing the
problem which is creating this random
output so what I can do that I can put
the synchronized keyword right before
the block of the code starts which is
thread sensitive and the way you do that
is you write synchronized and you supply
this which means Whoever has the current
who have whoever has the object of the
materials that whole object gets locked
for this particular block of code so
whoever has the mathematics object takes
a lock on the object for this particular
block of code if there were some other
code which was written in the get
multiples method before the synchronized
block or after the synchronized block
that block can be accessed by multiple
threads at the same time but this code
will only be accessible to one thread at
a time there will never be they will
never be a concurrent access to the
synchronized block That's The Power of
synchronized block and it will work the
exact same way so to show you if I run
this particular program I still get the
output in the same streamlined way where
first the multiples of 2 gets printed
and then the multiples of three get
printed so that's how you can actually
use synchronized methods or synchronize
block to make sure that one thread is
accessing a sensitive object at a time
and there will never be a scenario that
two threads are mutating the same object
at the same time again like I said be
very very cautious of when you use
synchronized blocks and when you use
threads because threads have one
predictable execution cycle execution
sequence basically and synchronized
blocks also have problems if you have if
you have thousands and thousands of
threads running in your application and
if you put synchronized on a particular
method your application May face severe
performance issues because all of the
threads will be executing that method in
a sequence imagine you put this onto a
huge application education or a huge
e-commerce application or a News website
it is it is going to create serious
performance issues so be very cautious
of how and when you use synchronized
method and the key to that is to have
that developer DNA to spot the code
which is causing this problem which
might be threat sensitive and maybe you
might need to change the code itself you
might not need to go into the
multi-threading scenario and you might
you might be able to fix it without
using the threading or synchronized
concept it completely depends but always
have a good trade-off when to use the
synchronized methods and synchronize
blocks let's get started with auto
boxing and unboxing in Java so if you
remember in the very first sessions I
talked about the primitive data types
and then later on we talked about the
objects for example we had the int data
type but there later we also saw an
integer data type which is which can
also pretty much do the exact same work
which int data type was doing and we saw
the similar kind of a experience for the
float data type and the float class
double data type and the double class
care data type and the character class
and so on so forth so Java provides an
easy way to convert a int data type
variable into an integer data type
variable and also back from integer data
type variable to an INT primitive data
type variable now you might be wondering
why we need that there would be
scenarios for example if you had an INT
array as in primitive int array and if
you want to store that into a collection
now collection can only be of type of
objects it cannot be a type of primitive
data type so you might need to convert
this int primitive data type array into
an integer object collection so you need
to do this conversion of into data type
to integer data type and there would be
cases where you invite you might need to
do vice versa so that's the basic idea
about Auto boxing and unboxing so when
we talk about the definition you can see
auto boxing is the automatic conversion
that the Java compiler makes between the
Primitive and their corresponding object
wrapper classes so whenever you are
converting a primitive data type to an
object class this is called Auto boxing
and when you do the reverse it is called
Auto unboxing or simply unboxing so
let's understand this with the help of
an example now so I am just going to
open an example about Auto boxing and
unboxing so that we can have a look at
it and here it is I've created a class
which is called Auto boxing demo it has
a public static void main method and
inside the method I am first simply
declaring an INT data type variable I
with the value 10 then if I need to auto
box this if I need to convert this
primitive value into an integer object
wrapper class or an integer class type
then I need to write the code like this
which says integer dot value off and
then you can supply the primitive data
type value and the output of it will be
of type integer class so you get an
integer object and then you can print
the object to check if it is
successfully doing the auto boxing or
not similarly doing the other way around
once I have converted this into an
integer object let's convert this back
to a primitive data type so from integer
object I'm converting this back into the
primitive data type and you see here
it's a simple assignment I just have to
assign the object to the primitive data
type and that's it I can do the same for
a character object and a cad data type
so first I create a character object
care obj and then if I have to unbox it
I can simply assign this CAD obj to a
care primitive data type CH and that
would be it so you can do the similar
drill for any other primitive to object
wrapper conversion let's say you want to
convert a floats data type to a float
class or you want to convert a double
data type to a double class then
whichever primitive data type has an
object wrapper class you can do the auto
boxing and auto unboxing like this
remember whenever you have to do Autobox
it means you're going from primitive to
object and for that you need to call the
value of method for example if you are
converting a double primitive to a
double object classically then you are
going to call double dot value of and
similarly the same kind of behavior will
be seen for other object wrapper classes
as well so for auto boxing you call the
value of and for auto unboxing you
literally just assign this to an
primitive and the object wrapper class
value will automatically be assigned to
the primitive data type so let's run
this now and observe the output so I had
the int I equal to 10 then I wanted to
convert this primitive into the object
wrapper and the way I can do that is by
calling the value of method and
supplying the primitive data types value
so that's why I'm doing it that's what
I'm doing here and this I obj should get
the 10 value now which I can see if I
print this is out and if I just print
the integer object all together I get
the value 10 so this concludes that I've
successfully I'm able to un auto box the
Primitive into an integer object now
looking at Auto unbox like I said you
simply can assign the object wrapper to
the primitive data type variable and
that should work as is and that's why at
line 15 we get this output which says
value of i1 is 10. similarly when we try
to Autobox the character object so I
have created a character object here and
then I want to unbox this back into a
simple car data type CH so when I print
CH I get the same value and when I print
the cat obj I again get the same value
remember the reason I have put this as
auto box is because this by default is
being stored into a care data type I can
also write it like this for example I
can say curve x equal to a and then I
can refer here as character dot value of
x this will pretty much have the same
impact or the same effect which I had
just now it is going to print the exact
same output if I read on this program
I'm going to get the exact same output
so this this basically concludes our
understanding that you can use the auto
boxing and auto unboxing pretty easily
whenever you have a scenario where you
want to convert the primitive data types
to the object wrapper classes or you
want to convert the object wrapper
classes back to the primitive data types
let's get started with IO in Java or IO
streams in Java so when we say IO it
basically means input output and the
basic idea is that your program takes an
input and gives you an output so
whenever you have to do some IO handling
generally the i o handling involves
taking input from some external Source
it can be the command line it can be
from a file it can be from another
consumer application it can be from a
hard disk but the basic idea is that
whenever you have to do that input
output handoff for input output
operation we call that as IO generally
whenever you will hear the term IO we
refer to the input output operations
with respect to the file system or the
hard disks or the external disks
basically now when we talk about streams
what is an i o Stream So the basic idea
is that you have an input source you
have an output destination now the way
that the input source sends the data to
the destination is via streams so
basically it converts the data into 1
and 0 and that one and zero travels as a
stream for example you can see this
pretty good image here where you have a
data source and you have a program and
your program is trying to read the data
from this data source which is basically
sitting on the file system and this data
gets converted into zeros and once and
then this is streamed to the program bit
by bit or piece by piece similarly when
the program wants to send the data back
to the data source it again goes in the
form of Stream So when we talk about
stream we also use the terms as input
stream or output Stream So a program
uses an input stream to read data from a
source remember whenever we are reading
we will call it as input stream and
whenever we are writing something we
will call that as output stream remember
that because I will be using this for
these particular terms again and again
in the demo so that's the basic idea
about streams that you convert this into
one and zero and input stream means
reading something and output stream
means writing something so now that we
have built that understanding let's have
a look at what kind of classes support
Java provides to do this IU streaming
operations so this is the Java i o
hierarchy where you have the object
super class and then you have different
types of streams stream classes so you
have input stream you have output stream
you have reader and you have writer so
if we talk about this particular section
in the input stream you have a file
input stream in the output stream you
have a file output stream this is
basically showing an inheritance
relationship so you have the input
streams for reading something you have
the output stream for writing something
and you have Java provides the classes
to write to read from a file or to write
to a file using the file input stream
and the file output stream class
respectively there are more classes
under it but only a few are few of them
are shown for Simplicity similarly if I
go to the right side I also have a
reader class and a writer class which
also have an input stream reader and
output stream reader and again these
have multiple other subclasses like file
reader preferred reader and file writer
so I will also try to showcase the
understanding of why we need this and
why we we need these I mean ultimately
you have to write a stream right so why
creating two different types of classes
I will come back to that in a while with
that understanding let's go into looking
at an example and let's build an
understanding of how do we work with
streams and this is also the session
where I will talk about the file
handling operations in detail so to
understand that I have created two
different examples one for byte stream
and one for character stream so let's
take that concept first why do you need
two different types of streams and the
reason is pretty simple whenever you are
reading data from some some data source
or writing data to the data source so
the data can either be simple character
strings like English characters or the
Unicode characters or it can be some
tabular data sitting in a table in a
database it can be an XML file it can be
an HTML file it can be literally
anything it can be a mathematical
expression file it can be an image you
don't know that so that's the reason
Java created two different types of
classes that if you want to work on a
particular file which is holding
characters then you can use character
stream and if you are dealing if you
don't know what kind of data the file is
going to contain then just use byte
streams character streams also
internally will be using the byte stream
only but it is much more simpler and
much more faster to use character
streams if you just have character files
also it is worth noting that when you
are using character stream the file will
be red character by character and when
you are using byte stream the file will
be read byte by byte so one byte at a
time and one character at a time so
let's look at the byte stream example
first I've created a class called byte
stream example it has a public static
voidbin method and then I am using the
file input stream and file output stream
classes basically what I'm am trying to
do in this example is I'm trying to read
a file and write to a file and like I
said the when we look at the theory
whenever we are using the input stream
term we are primarily doing a read
operation and whenever we are using the
output stream term we are writing
something to the file so for these kind
of operations Java provides for file
handling Java provides these two classes
which are called file input and file
output string so I create null
references and then I enter a try block
and inside the try block I basically
provide a location to read the file from
so I've created a source dot txt in the
Java tutorials location and if I show
you what this source file is containing
so if I go to this location Java
tutorials and if I open the source file
it just has a simple text which says
this is a sample text file let me delete
this desktop EXT for now so I just have
a source.txt here which is containing a
sample text this is a sample text file
so I am reading the source.txt using the
file input stream and storing the output
into this in stream which is a byte
stream and I'm also creating another
output stream where I will be writing
the destination file so I'm saying this
particular location write the file with
the name test.txt but these are still
just containers I haven't done much here
so you are going to initialize the
reading stream and the writing stream
and then you are going to read one byte
at a time till the time you reach the
end of the file the way to denote the
end of the file or the way Java tells
you that it you have reached the end of
the file is when the read operation
returns
-1 so you keep reading the file till the
read operation Returns the value as -1
whenever it Returns the value is -1 it
means that you have reached the end of
the file so I'm going to read this
source.txt byte by byte one byte at a
time till my re till I reach the end of
the file so I call in stream dot read I
store the output of in stream dot read
into a variable called content and at
the same time I also run this condition
that till the time this output is not
equal to -1 keep writing right where
right to the outstream so I want to
write to this particular Stream So I
call the right method and remember this
is a byte stream but here I the output
of in stream dot read was an integer
output so you need to convert this int
output to a byte by doing the explicit
casting here so we do the explicit
casting here so that the int content
gets converted into a byte type and then
outstreamed alt rights that byte inside
the stream onto this particular file so
that's what is happening here that you
load the in stream you read the file
byte by byte and you start writing the
output file byte by byte that's what you
do in this while loop once you have
reached the end of the file you will be
broken out of the while loop because the
whole file has been read and whatever
was written in that file has been
written to the outstream to this
particular file location and then in the
finally block you close both of the
streams remember it's very important to
close these resources otherwise these
resources will be present till the time
Java runs a garbage collection so it's
very important to make sure that you
close all the resources which you open
in terms of file handling these are
costly connections and they take up a
lot of memory so make sure that you
close them in the finally block and
that's why if you see I don't have a
catch block here but I've put the finely
block so that I can say I can seamlessly
close them so that is what I'm doing
here and now if I run this I don't get
any output because I'm not printing
anything but if I go to this particular
location and see if I have a desktop txt
so yes a desk.txt has just appeared
which was not there earlier and if I
double click on this it has the exact
same text as I had in my source.txt so
the source.txt and the desktop txt have
the same content because I've just
written the source.txt to the desk.ca
test dot txt so this is how you can use
byte stream operations to do file
handling now let's have a look at the
character stream example it is doing
exactly the same thing it's just that
you have to use different classes so
instead of file input stream and file
output stream we are going to use file
reader and file writer so I create the
file leader and file Adder references
let's call it as reader for Simplicity
and let's call this as writer so I
initialize file reader and file writer
again pointing to the same location it
will delete the desktop txt again so
that we can observe the output so I
create the object for a file writer and
file reader and I again the same thing I
call the read operation the read
operation is going to return an integer
value output and I am going to continue
reading the file character by character
this time the byte is not read but the
actual character of the file is being
read so I'm going to read this file
character by character till I reach the
end of the file which is denoted by this
condition and as the output is int I
need to convert this into care so I cast
the int output to a care output and then
write it to the writer then I close the
reader and writer both and that's it so
if I run this now and if I go back here
I will see desktop txt and I see the
output here exactly the same so in terms
of output there was no difference but
since this was a purely character file
the character stream demo is a better
use case or like file reader and file
leader classes are a better use case but
like I said there would be cases where
you have to read it as bytes because for
example if you're dealing with databases
or if you're dealing with another the
type of files for example image files
Etc that will be traveling as bytes so
using a byte stream might be a better
example in that case and that's that
holds true for any other different type
of data source as well let's get started
with using jdbc in Java to connect to
the databases in this example I am using
the open source Community Edition
postgresql but you can use any database
vendor provider if you want to if you
want to use Oracle or MySQL feel free to
do that but in this demo I'm going to
use postgres so you can download the
postgres windows installer since I'm
using a Windows machine here you can
download the installer from the official
postgresql.org website and you can also
download the jdbc driver for postgresql
going to this particular official
website which is jdbc dot
postgresql.org similarly you will be
able to find the jdbc driver for all
other database vendor providers as well
once you download this this is going to
download ajar for you and you can store
the jar anywhere like I've put this jar
into this particular location you can
see this latest jdbc driver jar for
postgresql so for every database vendor
there would be a different jdbc jar
which you need to download so that's
that you install the postgresql you set
up its database and when you install the
postgresql you also get a nice SQL
client to talk to the database because
database has a server and database has a
client right so to deal with that you
install the server and all these
database vendors like postgres Oracle
Microsoft SQL Etc they also provide a
nice Thin Client with it postgres also
provides a client when you install the
postgres server it will also ask you or
it will actually automatically install
the SQL client for it as well which is
called PG admin so this is how the PG
admin client looks like the current
edition of it is PG admin 4 so you will
get that installed automatically and
once your postgres server has been
successfully installed if you just go to
search and type PG admin you will get
this option once you click on this
option a new browser window will be
opened and you will see this client here
you will not see this particular window
let me let me close this one but you
will see something like this you will
see a server here so you can go inside
it you will see a postgresql Edition
here and if you go inside it you will
see a database here if you open the
database you will see the postgres
database by default created so you can
just right click on this and create a
database here you can name it as
whatever you want you can leave
everything as is for now and hit save
another thing which you need to do when
you do the installation is it will ask
you to set a database user and password
so choose whatever database username and
password you are comfortable with and
you will be using that user username and
password in your program as well so
create your database here and just leave
the database at this particular point
and now we will try to connect to this
particular database in the in the
example which I prepared I'm going to
connect to this test database so let's
go to the jdbc demo and see what is
happening there so for this purpose I
have created a class called jdbc demo it
has a public static void main method and
there's a lot going on here so let's
take it step by step and I will be keep
shuffling between the database SQL
client and this particular class to
build a nice narrative so if you think
carefully what you need to have if you
want to connect to a database the
obvious answer is the address of the
database where is the database you need
to know the location of the database to
connect to it so that is called the
connection URL every database vendor
will provide its own connection URL and
you can find that connection URL from
the official documentation there are
tons of examples available for it as
well but always refer to the official
deck documentation for that particular
database provider the general syntax is
jdbc colon your database vendor's Name
colon double slash the host name this
can be any IP address or your Local Host
generally we also put a port here
something like this 5432 is the port on
which the post rescql server runs but
again you can put the post the port here
on which your database server is running
every database vendor has their own
default Port the postgres SQL server has
the default Port as 5432 so you provide
the hostname you provide the port and
then you provide the database name you
provide the database name to connect to
so if you remember I told you that I
have written the program to connect to
this particular database called test so
whatever that be you provide that name
here and this is going to form the
connection URL I can remove this for now
but this is how the connection string is
going to look like and it is going to
its follow it follows the same format
for any database vendor that you say
jdbc colon you write the database vendor
name and then you say column double
slash you provide the host port and then
you provide the database name so that is
your connection URL after that to
connect to uh connect your Java program
to a database you need to use the
java.sql.connection class this is the
very critical class and very important
and probably the single most important
class which you need to have in your
program if you want to connect to a
database so you say connection con equal
to null I'm just creating a null
reference to it and before we go any
further let me also tell you why we need
this jdbc and what is actually this jdbc
so Java is a programming language it
does not comes with its own database but
there are multiple other vendors like
postgresql MySQL Microsoft SQL Oracle
Etc so Java wanted to provide a uniform
way to connect to all of these databases
because imagine all of these databases
building their own API contract it would
have been a nightmare for the developers
to connect to different databases or
shift from one database to other
database and that's the reason Java
created this nice interface called jdbc
and it said whoever wants to connect to
Java should follow this jdbc
specification and provide their
implementation similar to the the
interface and concrete class thing it's
not exactly that but you can think of it
in that manner that jdbc provides an
interface with the method declarations
and then Oracle postgresql MySQL all
these database vendors are supposed to
implement that interface and provide
their own implementation but jdbc apis
will always remain the same whoever
wants to connect to Java has to create a
driver and that driver contains that
implementation and that's the reason we
downloaded the jdbc driver and I will
come to how do we include that but
that's the background of jdbc and that's
why you need jdbc to build that uniform
contract and your vendor will provide
their own jar which will have the
implementation of the jdbc interface and
in this program what I'm trying to do is
basically I'm trying to insert a record
into a table so what is the table and
how do you create that so let's go back
here so in this test database you will
see a schema by default you will see a
public schema and you can create a new
schema if you want to or you can just
use the public schema so inside the
public schema you will go under and you
will see a an entry for tables so you
just right click and you say create
table you can also write in complete SQL
statement but I'm just showing you how
to do that in PG admin and you can give
the table name you can give the column
information and that's how you create
the table so I have created a table here
which is called student and the student
table has three columns roll number name
and age if I show you the exact query or
the whole create TDL for it it looks
like this so I created the student table
in the public schema which has a roll
number field a roll number column which
is of type numeric it has a name column
which is a varicare or a character
varying and it has a age column which is
again a numeric so roll number name and
age these are the three different
columns which I created inside the
student table so I have a student table
with these three columns so that's that
now let's go back to the program so I
have the student table and now I want to
insert some records in the student table
so let me just change the values here so
that we can see a different entry so I
have just hard coded some values
generally you will be getting these
values from somewhere in the program but
for Simplicity let's say you have got
those values once you have got those
values the next thing you need to do is
to build the SQL statement the exact SQL
statement which the postcard is which is
going to be run on the postgresql server
so you write that statement in this case
I'm showing you an a creation example so
it is going to be an insert query so I
say insert into table name which is
student and then I provide all the
column names it is always a better
practice to provide the column names in
these brackets even if you're inserting
the values to all the columns still
provide the column names so I say insert
into table column values and then you
provide the actual values as the roll
number variable which I created here the
name variable and the age variable
values so I just Supply the values here
remember the when you are inserting the
values roll number and age are integer
so you don't need to put any single
commas single inverted commas for it but
name is a string variable so I've put
this single inverted commas it's a
simple string concatenation nothing
fancy here so I'm just writing and a
plain SQL statement here and storing
that into a string once I have done that
the next piece which I need to do is to
get a connection to the database and the
way you are going to get a connection is
by this uniform method no matter which
database provider you are using you are
always going to use the driver
manager.getconnection method to get a
connection to the database and how do
you get the connection you supply the
connection URL you supply the username
to connect to the database and you
supply the password in this case I've
just set the username and password as
postgres and postgres so postgres is the
username and postgres is the password
pretty lame I accept but this is just
for demonstration purpose so it's fine
but generally you will be getting these
values from some application property
file so these are the three parameters
which you need to supply to this get
connection method and then you will get
a live connection to the database this
is this this is the line which is going
to make it all happen to connect to your
database server so if this line gets
executed successfully you have a live
connection once you have a live
connection the next thing which you
going to do is to create a statement
object on the connection statement is it
can be anything it can be an insert
statement or a select statement or
update statement or a delete statement
everything is a statement there right so
that's why you need to create a
statement object so you create a
statement object and then you execute
the SQL this insert SQL which you
prepared you're going to execute the SQL
here saying St dot execute update
execute update is the method which is
used for any insertion or deletion
operations so that's the method you are
going to use and supplying the SQL query
which you built with the actual values
of row number name and age the execute
update method Returns the number of rows
affected once this statement got run on
the database server or the SQL query got
run on the database server it might
impact one rows if it's just if it's an
insertion it might impact multiple rows
if it was an update query right so it is
going to return the number of rows
affected and that is what we are going
to use to check if my insertion
successfully went or my insertion failed
so if this execute update is going to
return 1 which means that my row got
inserted successfully in the database so
I'm just printing assist out here and if
any if this particular M returns 0 which
means none of the rows were affected by
my SQL query which means my insertion
operation failed so I'm just printing
assist out here and then I'm just
putting this in a catch block here to
print any error and finally closing the
connection this is again very very
important database connection is one of
the costliest connections you will be
creating when you will be writing your
Java applications always and always make
sure to close these database connections
otherwise your application is going to
face serious database bottlenecks so we
close the connection so that's all we
are doing here we prepare the URL we
prepare we just create a placeholder for
connection object we prepare our skill
query with all the relevant values we
get a connection to the database we get
a create statement we get a statement
object from the create statement method
and then we execute the statement and
then we can validate the statement
execution if there is a way to validate
it once you've done all of that you
close the connection so let's run this
program and see if we can see this new
record inside the student table and
before we do that let's also validate
what is present in the student table as
of now so if I go here and I say view
all rows this is just going to run a
select star on the student table so
currently student table has one record
with rule number one name as John and
ages 20. and now I am trying to insert
another row with row number 2 name as
Jane and age as 22 so if I right click
and run as Java application I get this
entry which says inserted successfully
which is coming from here inserted
successfully and it also prints the
exact SQL so that you can see what SQL
actually got executed on the database
server this is the same string SQL which
I built so this is the SQL which got run
on the server which said insert into
student values and the roll number the
roll number was 2 and the name was Jane
with single inverted commas because this
was a string and then age was 22. this
was the exact SQL which got executed so
my SQL has been executed my connection
has been closed if I go back to the pg
admin client and if I try to rerun this
query now I get two records so if you
remember this record was already there
but now I get the second entry which is
the new entry which just got inserted
because I did I ran the program and you
see the roll number two the name as Gene
and the age as22 so this was a very
simple example to show you how you can
do the jdbc correction but one of the
things which I still haven't covered is
the usage of the jdbc driver the jar
which I talked about so the way you are
going to add the jar is you go to the
project you right click on the project
you go to the build path go to the
configure build path and there you will
see different tabs Source projects
libraries so go to the libraries Tab and
select the class path here and you can
choose the add external jars option
click on this load your SQL jdbc jar for
your particular database vendor for my
case it was post SQL let me just quickly
remove this chart and show you right
from how it's done so this is how it
will look like for you you select the
class path you click on ADD external
jars you go to the location where you
have downloaded your jdbc driver jar for
your particular database select that
click open it will come here hit apply
and close that's how the jar is going to
be there if you don't provide the jar
your program is going to fail miserably
it is not going to work so make sure
that you have the jar and then only it
is going to be able to create a
successful connection and be able to
successfully execute the query remember
jdbc provides the the specifications and
then the particular database vendor like
postgresql provides their jdbc driver
which has the implementation for that
jdbc API and that the Java has this
uniform jdbc Avi API and every database
vendor is expected to honor and
Implement that API only so that Java
developers can work on the jdbc contract
and everything should work as is let's
get started with generics in Java so
before we go about generics let's
understand why do we need generics and
what what was the requirement that led
to the creation of generics so as we
know that when we work in any object
oriented programming language we created
classes we create objects we create
variables and everything has a type
everything has a type and the type is
static the type cannot be changed that's
why we call Java as a strong type
checking language at compile time it
checks the types of the variables of the
classes at the compile time and if the
classes are mismatching or their types
are mismatching then you basically get a
compilation error but what we see as we
as we moved along we saw that we were
creating the similar kind of
functionality again and again in
different classes for example if there
is a login functionality which should
allow a person to log in and we should
also allow an application to login then
these are the two different use cases
but the functionality Still Remains the
Same so how would the login
functionality allow both of the types of
entities be it user or application to
get into the application or login into
the consumer application how do you do
that and that's what led to the creation
of generics that you can reuse the same
code with different types of inputs
remember the stress here is on the types
and that's what it is mentioned here
that we will like to reuse the same code
with different inputs we will just keep
changing the type parameters and we'll
keep using the same same code again and
again it has some benefits over the
non-generate code like we mentioned like
I mentioned earlier that when we work
with the not generic code we have the
statically assigned types to the
variables and objects and if we use
generics then we don't have to do that
and at the same time you don't even have
to explicitly cast them already touched
upon this concept of uh generics in
different bits and pieces in different
sessions throughout this tutorial Series
where we saw that whenever I was
creating a list I was supplying this
type into these buckets right and I told
that this that this is the generic type
but now we'll go deeper into this
concept and we'll see how we can create
our own generic types if Java does not
provide it so with that let's move to an
example and see how we can Implement our
own generic types to create generic code
where we can supply the types
dynamically so I've prepared an example
for this I've actually prepared two
examples for this and we'll go through
both of them one by one so here what I'm
doing that I'm creating any class you
can think of it as any class holding any
functionality which is applicable to
multiple entity types think of it as the
same login class which I just talked
about so if your class has a
functionality which should be reused by
many different types then one of the way
to not repeat the code or repeat the
class or repeat the functionality again
and again is to make that class use a
generic signature and how you do that
you write the class name and then you
put these brackets and you just type T
you can write any variable a b c or
whatever you feel like but T is sort of
the default standard the Java developers
have been using since generics was
launched so you put this T here now
whoever calls this class or whoever
whoever initializes this class will have
to supply the type of the class on which
this particular functionality is going
to get executed now remember the
collection examples I took I took in the
past series what if this was a list
class because we have use the exact same
syntax right we use list we put brackets
and then we wrote string and we said
okay now this list is a list of strings
if we said list of integer then we just
write integer in these brackets and that
list became a list of integers so you
see the same list was being reused for
different data types and the exact same
concept is applied here for your custom
classes and your own custom
functionality so I write T here then I
can do whatever with this T I want so I
just put a reference of it inside the
class I create a Constructor Constructor
is also assigning the T type I do a get
object and that's all it's a very simple
toy example but just to get the point
across you can write as complex logic as
you want inside the class depending upon
your use case but this is just a
straightforward example that you can use
generics in the classes as well once you
do that then how do you initialize this
class so let's have a look at that as
well so I've just created a public
static voidbin method inside the same
class obviously you can create this
method outside the outside this class as
well there's no stopping that logic but
but for the sake of Simplicity I've just
put the main class here so it's a simple
public static void vein method there I
am initializing the single generic
holder class the same class and here the
T type is of integer this T type can be
of anything else as well for example
your own student class can also be
supplied here and then this single
generic Holder will become of student
type in this case I'm just using a
pre-built Java class so this single
generic folder Becomes of integer type I
give a reference I create an object and
I provide a value to the object because
you see the Constructor is this whatever
T you supply so if the t is the integer
this T becomes integer and this obj is
going to hold the value 10 because
that's the Constructor being called here
and after that you can do whatever you
want in terms of the logic here I'm just
I just have I just have a get object
method so I'm just calling that method
and printing the object that's all
similarly you can also initialize the
same class with the string type so you
see I'm reusing the same class in the
same functionality again and again for
different class types so this time I'm
using the string type in instead of
integer and I'm supplying a string
parameter this time and this this
Constructor still will work because this
is generic when you create it with
integer this Constructor this T became
of integer type and when you initialized
it with the string type this Constructor
started accepting the string objects so
you just Supply a string called simply
code and then I call get object so let's
run this method so when we run the main
method from the first invocation at line
16 and 17 when you call the get object
the value of the object gets printed
which is 10 for the integer and then at
line 20 the value of the string gets
printed which is simply code so that is
how you can use generics inside a class
or for a class now there might be use
cases where you have to create a class
which can accept multiple types of
generic types let's take an example if
you remember when we talked about
hashmap we had the exact same situation
so you had the key and you had the value
now key can be of any type any data type
it can be string integer whatever and
then value can also be of any data type
it can also be your custom data types
for example the key becomes a roll
numbers and the value becomes student
object so map is a situation where you
have two generic types so I'm just
trying to replicate that similar kind of
behavior that if we have to create a
class with two three as many generic
types as you want you can still do that
by just providing a comma here you can
go on doing as many generics as you want
in this example I'm using two generics
and then it again goes to the same drill
that I've created references for both D
and U I have initialized both T and U in
the Constructor and then I have a
display method which is going to call
the display the obj1 and obj2's values
or there are two string Methods
basically because when you when you try
to call the object inside the
system.out.print Ln method the by
default the tostring method of the
object will automatically get caught so
that's all I have in this particular
class so I it's a simple class accepting
two different types of generics and then
calling the display method and here is
the public static white main method for
the same here I am initializing the Dual
generic class and here the t is string
and U is integer so these T and U are
assigned these class types and then I
create the class I again write the same
types and I provide the value so for the
string one I provide simplicode for the
integer one I provide 10 this
Constructor gets called obj1 gets the
value simply code and obj2 gets the
value 10 and then I call display method
there I am printing obj1 and obj2 so
let's run this method okay I'm getting
simply code in 10 because when I call
the display method at line 13 obj1 gets
printed obj1 is holding simply code
value and at line 14 obj2 gets printed
or the two string method of the obj2
gets printed which is holding the value
10. so this was a quick tour to tell you
how can you use generics you can
obviously use generics in the variable
types as well you can use generics in
the method argument types as well
wherever you want the simple idea is
that one you would like to reuse the
functionality again and again and second
you would like to you would not like to
have a strong strict type checking and
like I said try to relate these generic
concepts with the collection framework
we listen because collection framework
is completely built upon the concept of
generics whenever we initialize a list
or a map or headset or a linked list or
error list or anything we always Supply
the type and that type is coming from
these if you look at the implementation
of error list class you will see that
let me see if I can open that for you to
show you how that looks like if I go to
an example of Collections and if I try
to just open the class you will be able
to see that yep so if I click on this
list class you see list of E-Type so
here e is the type which you are going
to supply so in this particular case
when you say list of integer this
integer gets typed into e so whatever so
this this whole list class whatever
operations you are doing inside the list
class will be applied for the integer
type so similarly you can look at other
collection classes and you will always
see these generics everywhere in the
collection classes let's get started
with string handling in Java so we have
been dealing with string types
throughout different sessions in this
whole series but in this session we are
going to look at lot of different
utility methods which the string class
provides string class is very versatile
in Java and it provides lot of Handy
functions which can help you manipulate
strings in multiple ways for example if
you want to trim a string or if you want
to append a string to another string or
if you want to find a particular
character at a particular index or if
you have an index and you want to see
what character is present at that
particular index or if you want to do
any other kind of pattern matching in
the string so string is very versatile
in that in that context and today we
will have a look at some of those
methods so I've just opened the Java
docs API for string and you can see in
the method summary you will find a long
list of methods we will go through some
of these methods for example if I just
show you a snapshot of what I'm talking
about it has a Care Act method so you
provide a index and integer index and
this particular method will tell you
which character is present at that
particular index in the string remember
string is basically a 0 based character
array zero index based character array
similarly you can also call code point
at which is going to return the
character in the Unicode code point at a
specified index similarly compared to
Method can be used to compare two
strings with each other compared to
ignore cases also there which can
compare two strings ignoring whether
they are in upper case or lowercase you
can use concat method to join two
strings together you can use the
contains method to find if a particular
character or a particular sequence of
character exists in a particular string
or not you can do a Content matching you
can do copy you can also see if a
particular string ends with a particular
character or a sequence of characters so
there are tons of different methods
available here and please do check out
the API because like I said this is
going to come very handy when you start
writing real-time projects or the real
life projects so with that knowledge
let's go to our IDE and let's have a
look at some of these examples in action
so here also you can obviously have a
look at the string class from the IDE
itself just right string and hit Ctrl
and you will see an uh underline and a
hyperlink so just click on this and you
in the string class will be opened and
you can actually read on about the
documentation of the whole string class
but we are not going to do that we are
going to have a look at some real life
examples of how we can use different
methods of the string class so here I've
created two strings str1 and str2 str1
is holding a string which says John is
studying and str2 is holding a string
which says in college now the first
utility function which I'm going to talk
about is the length method so if you
want to find out what is the length of
this particular string then you can just
call the length method on the string and
that is going to return the length of
the current string let's see that in
action let me comment the rest of the
code and let's see this one in action so
if I run this program I get the value
16. so if you count this 1 2 3 4 space
is also counted 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14
15 16. so you get the exact length of
the string when you call the length
method similarly another method is
concat Method and concat method is used
to concatenate two strings together
concatenation basically means joining
two strings together so if you want to
join the string 1 and string two then
just call str1 Dot concat with the
string you want to append or you want to
concat so the concat method on the left
Heights left hand side of the string is
going to get concatenated with the
argument which you passed in the concat
method so let's see that in action now
and let's see the result as well because
I'm storing the result of concatenation
into a new variable and printing that
variable so I get this whole text here
and you see the studying in just got
merged there was no space in between
because there is no space here if you
just put it like this and if you rerun
this you will see the proper space as
well while concatenation one of the
things which I also want to call out is
strings are immutable in nature when I
say immutable it it means that once you
have created this str1 holding this
value then St and then this particular
object's value pointing to str1 cannot
be changed you cannot mutate the strings
if you try changing str's value Java is
going to create a new object and point
str1 to that object but the object which
was created initially is not going to be
overwritten so remember that concept
that whenever you are doing
manipulations on the string the previous
string object Still Remains there it
doesn't get overwritten or it doesn't
get modified whenever you modify a
string you get a new object that's the
property of string so we saw the
concatenation let's move ahead uh this
also format method format method is used
to dynamically populate some parts of
the string for example if you have long
list of students and if you want to
print the name of students then what you
can do here is that you can change you
can assign those names to certain
variables and you can point or refer
those variables in the string with the
percentage syntax percentage s syntax
basically so the string dot format
method is used to supply Dynamic values
inside a static string so in this case
this part of the string is static where
I'm saying the name of the student is
then in the next string remember plus
also can concatenate it it is also doing
the exact same thing as the concat
method okay it's just a shorthand so I'm
creating first string then I'm creating
second string but here I'm writing
percentage S I will come to that and
then I have created one more string
where I'm using percentage B so what
happens that Java format method supports
certain special type of references for
example if you want to dynamically place
a string you can use percentage s if you
want to dynamically place an integer
value you can write percentage D in The
Format method similarly you can also
write other percentage f for for a float
value and there are more other similar
placeholders which are available in the
format method so do check out the format
method documentation if you want to know
what all percentage types or variable
types can be dynamically placed inside
the format method here I am just using
percentage s and percentage D and then
once you have created the first part of
the format method which is string with
with Dynamic placeholders till this
particular point then you put a comma
and you start providing the values
remember the sequence of the values have
to be exactly the same way in which you
have used them here so if percentage s
is coming first then you have to supply
a string value if percentage D is coming
after that after the string values you
have to provide an integer value if
there was another percentage s after
percentage D in the same string then
after 21 you had to provide another
string value so that's the contract
which format method needs to honor and
if I run this particular program and if
I say if I try to see the output let's
try to see the output as well and for
the output I need to store this whole
string.formats output into a variable so
let's say I say string R and then I can
print R and see what comes out so that's
it let's run the program now and now you
will see this line the name of the
student is John comma and the age is
variable is 21. I think it's coming
because I've just wrote variable is here
but if you if you remove this and if you
say the age is percentage D then you
will get a nice human readable output
without any extra formatting so the name
of the student is John and the age is 21
and that there was a comma that's why
you still see the comma but this is the
basic idea with using the format method
now another method which I want to talk
about is a Care Act method let me
comment the previous output so that we
can follow along so I'm just going to
comment all of this which we have
covered already and let's focus on the
Care at method so Care Act method can be
used to find the character present at a
particular index in a string so whatever
index you specify in the Care at method
the character present at that particular
index will be returned so when I say
str1 dot Care at 5 remember strings are
0 based indexed character arrays so 0 1
2 3 4 5 at 5 I is present so this Care
at method should return I so if I run
this particular program yes I see the
output as I now let's move ahead uh with
next example or the next API call the
next API call is the usage of equals
method where I can see if the two
strings are equal or not so here I'm
saying str1 dot equals str2 if both
strings are same it is going to return
true otherwise it is going to return
false so if I run this I get the output
as both strings are different it goes in
the else block because str1 and str2 are
different they are holding different
values so here the exact content of the
string is going to be matched the next
one is the index of method so index of
method can be used just for the reverse
functionality of care add in carat we
were supplying the index and getting the
character here we can supply the
character and get the index of it so
what what is going to happen that you
write the string dot index of and then
you supply the character which for which
you want to find the index of so I
Supply y here and if I run this
particular program for this line the
output is 12. let's see if the output is
correct so here if you try to find what
is sitting at the index number 12 in
this
string so again 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
11 12. so yes Y is present at the 12th
index and that's the output I get what
if you provide a character which is not
present in this particular string that
says Z which is not there and see what
the output is in that case you will get
the output as minus one so if the
character is not present in the string
you will get the output as -1 another
thing what if the character is uh
present more than once in the string for
example I is present more than one time
in the string so if I write I here
whether I get the index of this I or
this I let's see so I'm going to run
this program again and I get the value 5
so 5 is basically this I because this I
is definitely not 5 it's far farther
index so the first match of the index is
going to be returned in terms of the
index of method okay so that was about
the index of let's look at the next one
which is the replace in replace it's as
the name suggests you can replace a
character or a sequence of characters in
a string by calling the replace method
on the string on which you want to do
the manipulation and remember you are
doing the manipulation here so the
previous object is not going to get
overwritten but a new object is going to
get created so what I want to replace is
with r so in this particular string I
see An Occurrence of s here so this s
should be replaced with r if the replace
functionality works as I just explained
so let's run this program and yes I can
say instead of s i see R being replaced
there and that's the usage of the
replace method next one is the split
method where if you want to split the
string into multiple elements so you
just call the split method and you
provide the separator here I am
separating the string Whenever there is
a space I'm basically breaking up the
string into multiple substrings that's
what I'm doing here for are multiple
strings I would just call it as so
whatever separator you provide whenever
the string is going to encounter that
separator it is going to split one part
of it so in on providing the separatory
space it means in this particular case
I'm going to get three items the first
breakup is going to go going to happen
here so the John part of it will go out
and space will go out in a separate
string then again between is and
studying I have another space so there
will be another break here so I should
get three elements if I call the split
method one element will be holding the
value John the second element will be
holding the value is and the third
element will be holding the value as
studying and then I'm printing all the
elements of the of the array remember
that split method returns a string array
so that's what I'm using here to store
the output of the split method and then
I'm just using the streams API to
iterate over this string array
outputting or printing the each element
of the array so let's run this program
okay okay so I can see three different
outputs through this system dot out DOT
println first John then is then studying
like I said split method is going to
create a three element size array of
strings because I'm separating it based
on the space the last utility function
which I want to talk about so this is
the last one but I'm skipping some of
some more and due to the interest of the
time but like I said do check out the
documentation to read or understand more
about other string utility methods which
I'm not covering here in this session so
the last one I'm going to talk about is
the substring method and substring is
basically going to take a mini string
out of the long string so what if you
want to trim the string what if you have
a long string and you only want to get a
part of the string so you can specify
the starting point we can specifying the
you can specify the end point and
whatever string characters are present
between the starting index and the end
index will be taken out from the string
and you can store that output into a new
string and print that so here I'm
calling the substring method providing
the starting index as 1 and the ending
index is 5. let's run this program and
interpret the output so I'm getting the
output as o h n so what is happening
here let's go back to the str1 so I said
start with one remember string is a zero
based index so it starts with 0 1 it
starts with o because o is present at
the first index and then I'm going up
till 5 so 1 gets printed whatever
character is present at one index get
printed second index get printed third
index gets printed fourth index gets
printed which is just a space and then
the fifth index is I which is not
printed here so it means that when you
call the string substring method then
the end index Position will not be
printed it starts from the beginning
index and it will go till index by end
index minus one position in terms of
printing because if you select this
you'll see an extra bar here because the
space is also getting printed so it is
printing everything before the fifth
index it will not include the fifth
index character remember that when you
use the substring functionality that the
end index is not included in the
substring if you want to include that
you need to increase the index by one so
for example if you want to print I as
well then you have to write it as 10th
index as 6 and if you run this then you
will also see I now yep so that is how
this substring functionality Works let's
get started with java.lank package so
java.lank package is one of the most
core and fundamental packages in Java
which is provided out of the box to the
developer you never explicitly import
this package in your Java program
because you don't need to Java provides
this automatically the moment you create
a file with DOT Java extension or and
you have you are running that particular
program inside or on a jdk you get the
java.lank package automatically for
example when we were when we were
running the string handling demo I was
using the string class but I never
imported this string class you can see
there is no import for string because
string class is also part of the
java.lank package it's automatically
imported for you you never need to
explicitly import the package for any
classes of that package so this is going
to be more of a theoretical lecture
where we will just have a look at our
quick overview of all the java.lank
package classes and other utilities you
don't need to remember all the classes
and utilities but this is just to give
you a sense of what all it contains so
in terms of the interfaces it has the
appendable interface Auto
closable Care sequence clonable
comparable if you remember we also used
comparable when we were writing the
comparable implementation to compare
different objects in a collection so
this also comes automatically as part of
the java.lank package I travel runnable
again we use this in the in the
threading example so this also comes
automatically to you you never need to
import the enable class from the
java.lank package when we move to the
classes all the data type classes which
you can think of in terms of Boolean
byte character class class loader
compiler enums even float integer long
math so all the classes which we were
using the the data type classes which we
were using in different examples are
also part of the java.blank package okay
so this is a long list long list it also
has a thread class so whenever you are
creating thread you again never imported
thread class but it's still just worked
fine because there was uh this was also
coming as part of the java.lank package
there are also bunch of enumerations
which it provides in terms of Unicode
thread State Etc it also provides
exception classes like arithmetic
exception or or the different runtime
exceptions which we dealt with like
array index out of bound array store
Class cast class not supported the root
exception class so lot of exception
classes also come as part of the
java.lank package it also provides some
error classes if you remember when we
talked about the exception framework you
have the error types and you have of the
exception types so it also provides some
error classes if you want to use that
you don't you never need to import any
of these classes and you will
automatically get them from the
java.line package similarly it also
provides some annotations as well like
functional interfaces or you remember we
use this annotation a lot the add the
rate override annotation but we never
imported the override class or the
override annotation because it's part of
the java.line package so this basically
tells us that there are a lot of
different classes utilities enums errors
exceptions data types which are provided
out of the box from the java.lank
package which makes our life so much
easier whenever we want to work with
Java because we don't need to import the
very basic classes which which we use
very frequently and another very
important package is the java.util
package we have been using the java.util
package in all of the collections
examples and tutorials we walk through
in this whole tutorial Series so let me
just open the java.util package for you
so if I go here to java.util and I will
be able to see the java.util packages
different classes Etc yes so here is
here it is the java.util package and
remember java.util package is not
imported automatically you have to
explicitly import the java.util package
to use the clutches of it so it so
that's the difference between java.lank
package and java.util package that you
cannot you can use the classes coming
from the java.lank package without
explicitly importing those glasses or
importing the java.blank package but
java.util package is something which you
have to explicitly Import in your Java
program to make it work or even make it
compiled so what java.util provides
first of all the collections framework
the whole collections framework comes
from the java.util package so for
example all the interfaces which we use
while we work with the collections
framework classes interfaces like
collection list set map you can see the
map interface you can see the list
interface with the generics so all the
interfaces which we use from in the
collections framework are present in the
java.util package similarly when we talk
about the classes all the concrete
classes implementation of the
collections framework in terms of error
list linked list hashmap hash set preset
Stream app you will see all of those
classes here here we are covering all
the this is showing all the classes
summary so you see some abstract classes
and you will also see some concrete
classes as you move further down in this
particular list so you see hashmap you
see hash set hash table linked hash map
linked headset linked list we used all
of these classes while we were going
through the collections framework
tutorials so it provides all of these
and lot of other classes like the
scanner class which we covered in the
Java project for taking the inputs from
the command line from the U user stack
class again from the collection some
time classes and it also provides bunch
of enumerations like the Locale
basically setting the language
categories for a particular program it
also provides some exceptions which we
used while we were working with the
collections framework so most of these
exceptions are or some of these
exceptions are related to the collection
classes for example the concurrent
modification exception gets thrown
whenever you and your the whole
execution detects concurrent
modification of an object when such
modification is not allowed you will see
other different types of exceptions like
illegal format Etc in this particular
exception section of this particular
package then it also provides just one
error class as well so this is what the
java.util package contains and just to
refresh your memory whenever we ran any
collection demo we always imported the
java.util classes you can see this is
all coming from java.util so this is
something which you have to import
without which year program will not even
compile so that's also one of the
difference between the java.lank package
and the java.util package and that's
pretty much all I want to cover in this
particular session so we basically did a
quick tour of the java.line package and
the Java dot util package and like I
said it's impossible to cover all of
that or all of the classes and enums and
interfaces and errors and exceptions
with all the examples so I would suggest
you to just keep this in mind about the
java.lank package in java.util package I
told you the basic construct that
java.lank contains all the types the
class and the variable types or the data
types we dealt with and java.util
majorly contains all the collection
classes uh that's that's the that's the
basic thing which you need to remember
whenever you work with Java and your
java.lank package never needs to be
imported but java.util package needs to
be imported always whenever you use the
util classes let's get started with
networking in Java so when we talk about
the networking in Java Java has a whole
dedicated package called java.net
package which has all the different
classes which you need to have to write
a networking program in Java so we'll
you will see bunch of classes with two
classes most important ones which are
inet 4 address and inet 6 address so as
you can you can understand that inet 4
address is the class which can be used
to represent the ipv4 addresses and inet
6 address class can be used to represent
IPv6 addresses and then you can learn
about sockets it also has socket classes
it has lot of interfaces with the
prominent one being the networking
interface there are some high level apis
for example the URI class is there which
can be used to represent a universal
resource identifier as specified in the
RFC and this is just an identifier this
doesn't provide the means to access the
resource if you want to access the
resource then you need to use URL which
is the class representing the Universal
resource locator which is a slightly
older concept than URI but with URL you
can hold the address as well as access
the address URL connection is also one
of the class which is Created from the
URL class to set up a communication link
with the URL and similarly HTTP URL is
for an HTTP connection and you have
protocol handlers there are a lot of
interesting classes which you can
explore if you want to learn more about
what all networking support Java
provides but when we talk about the
basic ones like ipv4 address the URL UI
classes these are the ones which
generally most developers interact with
if you want to write a socket
programming uh socket program then you
can still do that with the classes and
interfaces support provided by Java so
you can see bunch of interfaces here
cookie policy socket option then in
terms of classes you can see again
content Handler cookie manager HTTP
cookie inet 4 and 986 address with the
classes which I talk about it also has a
generic class but we I would always
recommend to use one of these if you
know what address you are dealing with
the URL connection the jar URL
connection class proxy class some bunch
of socket classes URI URL classes and
some enums and exceptions as well which
are related to networking connections
for example malformed URL if the URL
itself is is not correct then you get a
malformed URL exception socket exception
if there's a socket timeout exception
then also you have a dedicated exception
for that so there are a bunch of
different exceptions classes enums and
interfaces available which you can have
a look at if you want to dig deeper into
it so I've also prepared a demo where we
will be using some of these
functionalities of these of this
particular package so let's jump to the
IDE and see what I've built so here I
have created a class called networking
demo and what we are trying to do that
we will provide the simply launch URL
and we will try to get bunch of
information about about how this website
is hosted so you just create a simple
string variable and you can type any
string you can write any favorite
website of your choice here and then we
create the inet address class and like I
said you always use the concrete
implementation of the inet address class
which is in this case inet 4 address so
I use the get by name and we Supply the
URL to get an inet address object and
what does inet address contains it
contains all the information in terms of
the internet address on which that
particular website is hosted so you will
see lot of different functionality in
this class let's explore some of the
functionality and methods which are
provided by the inet address class so
once you do this you will get an initial
address object if the URL is correct if
the URL is incorrect you will get a
malformed URL exception anyways if you
want to just see the address of the IP
address where this particular website is
hosted it you can call the get address
method and if you want to see the host
address method then you can call the get
host address now you might be wondering
what is the difference between get
address and get host address so let's
get first that out let me comment the
rest of the code and let's first focus
on this particular part so let me
comment the local address part as well
we will come to that in a while and I
can just remove this comment so we are
printing the get address and the get
host address and let's see what values
do we get and how do we see if it's a
different value so this explains right
when we call init address dot get
address we just get all the values as we
know that when we deal with ipv4 address
the address has four values something
dot something dot something dot
something if you want to verify it just
go to your own laptop and you will be
able to see some others like
192.168.something.something so that so
IP ibv4 address has four sections and
all the four sections will have some
values so if you use the get address
method and you try to convert this into
a string it basically will return an
array the get address method will return
an array which will look like this but
if you want to see it exactly in the
format in which the real world
networking protocols understand it then
use the get host address which is going
to show it exactly in the way in which
we write the IP address where we write
some integer dot some integer dot some
integer dot some integer so that's the
difference between get address method
and get host address method same value
different representation the next
function which I'm going to talk about
is about local address and the local
address or the method name is is any
local address so this method is going to
tell me if there is a wildcard address
which is associated with this particular
host you can also see what this method
is doing from the documentation so if
you go to the documentation and if you
search for this particular method in the
inet 4 address class you will see it
says utility routine to check if the
inet address is a wild card address the
result will be a Boolean which will
indicate if it has a wildcard address or
not so let's run this program and
understand if it has a wildcard address
no there is no wildcard address
Associated for this particular website
similarly there is another method which
we can explore which is is link local
address so let's search for the
documentation of it first so this is the
class if you search it it will just show
you the exact class which is present
with the method and this method provides
basically a check to see if the inet
address is a link to a local address
within the domain of the website so the
result again will be a Boolean if it
says true it means there is a link to
the local address and if it returns
false it means the address is not a link
local unicast address so let's see the
output of this in with respect to the
simply learn website so if I run this
program now I again get false so there
is no wildcard address at attached but
associated with the website and it does
not point to a local unicast address
either is there a loopback mechanism now
these all are networking Concepts and
since this is not a networking session
so I will not go deeper into what what a
loopback address means in detail but to
get to give you an understanding of
where it present and how you can use
this in Java is what we are going to
focus on so if you want you can always
read about what is the loopback address
but if you want to know if the URL which
you are pointing to is uh the address
which is returned by that website has a
loopback address or not then you can use
the islu back address method and this
again returns true or false based on
whether it has a loopback address or it
does not have a loopback address so if I
run this particular program I get the
output false again so no it the
simpleton website does not even also
have a blue back address the last one or
the second last one which I want to
explore is the site local address method
so let's see what does this method do
let me just remove this extra commented
lines so let's look at the documentation
of this method so this is a utility
routine to check if the init address is
a site local address the result is a
Boolean indicating if the init address
is a site local address or false if the
address is not a cyclical site local
unicast address again this concept is
again a networking special concept for
similar to the loopback address so this
is just basically showing if the site
also has a a basically a local unicast
address associated with it or not so if
you want to see the site local address
output I have enabled that code and if
you run this particular program we get
false for that as well yes that means
that the the simple website is built
with pretty good practices there is no
loopback address there is no site local
address which we don't need for for this
particular website in this case the last
one is just a simple thing just to see
the hash code it's not much of a
relevance mostly the programs but just
to tell you that this is also available
so you can also see the hash code which
is contained by the inet address object
so we covered bunch of functionality in
this particular example we had a look at
the java.net package it has an inet 4
address class and inet 6 address class
lot of networking exceptions and
interfaces support as well and the
simple way to use it is to you point it
to a website call the get by name call
the get host address and you will get
the IP address in the exact format in
which the networking World deals with it
similarly you can call the get address
to just get an array of it just as we
saw here and then there are a lot of
utility functions available in the inet
address class like is any local is link
local is loopback is site local and
there are actually more if you look at
this class you will find more methods
here in terms of what like for example
it also has is multicast address this is
basically to check if the unit address
is an IP multicast address so there are
a lot of different methods here there
are some MC methods as well which will
check which are specially created for
the multicast address scenarios so a
utility routine to check if the
multicast address has a global scope if
it has a local scope or or sorry it has
a node scope basically or it has a link
scope or it has a site scope so there
are a lot of different methods available
for the multicast as well which you can
have a look at and we already covered
the get address the get host address and
the hash code address classes there are
some URL classes as well like I
mentioned URL UI classes are also very
important classes which you might need
to use whenever you are you are building
a connection with a particular
application based on their URL if you
are doing socket programming there are
socket classes available which you can
also use while using the networking
Concepts in Java so you can build a
pretty decent and robust application uh
using the networking classes and the
networking support provided by Java to
build a networking application let's get
started with image handling in Java so
we deal with images on a daily basis and
you will often be required to deal with
image handling in Java programs as well
where you might need to re read an image
or write an image or load an image into
memory and do other kind of
manipulations on the images so Java does
provide support for image handling as
well and you can pretty much load any
type of image be it a gif image or be it
a PNG or be it a JPEG image basically it
converts into a Java 2D image to render
it and it basically creates a byte
representation of the image to serve and
save the contents so in this section we
are going to talk about the image
handling aspects of java and to do that
there are broadly two classes which Java
provides as you can see in this official
documentation the first one is java.awt
dot image class and the second one is
java.awt.image.buffered imageclass which
extends the image class so this is
basically the super class as you can see
here which you can use to represent any
kind of graphical image as a 2d array of
pixels and buffered image is a concrete
implementation of the image class which
you can use to construct instances of
the class and buffered images is sort of
the I would say the de facto standard or
the go to class whenever you are dealing
with any kind of image rendering uh
tasks in a Java program and we will also
have a look at how we can use the
buffered image class to basically read
and a sample image and also write a
sample image to a file system so you can
read more about this in the
documentation and these are also bunch
of documentations available in terms of
how you can read it how you can load it
into the program how you can draw an
image how you can create and save the
image Etc and like I mentioned we will
be covering some aspects of it in
today's demo as well so this was a very
brief theoretical introduction about
image handling and like I always
mentioned if you want to know more about
this do check out the official
documentation of of java where you can
learn more about the image handling
classes and utilities so with that let's
move to the demonstration part so I have
prepared a demo here which talks about
image handling so I have created a class
called image handling demo which has a
public static void main method and I'm
just giving some some sample uh
dimensions for the image in terms of
width and height here and then as I
mentioned that we will be using the
buffered image class so I'm creating an
a reference for the buffered image it's
currently assigned to null so basically
there's nothing and then I am calling
the method read from file so like I
mentioned you can you mostly will be
dealing with reading from an image or
writing to an image so here we will look
at both of the aspects as to how you can
load an image from your file system into
a Java program and then write it back to
the file system from your Java program
so let's first look at the read from
file method which we will tell us how we
can read a Java file so I provide some
sample Dimensions these Dimensions will
vary based on your use case and I Supply
the buffered image object inside that I
have created a try block and in the try
block the first thing you need to do for
image handling is to basically create a
file object because image is also
technically just a file right so you
provide the file image path here at this
particular location so let's go to the
sample image bar this is the destination
path and let me open the sample image
path as well which is somewhere in the C
drive so this is the image which we are
loading this is the path which I have
mentioned which is C sample dot jpg so
let's first have a look at the image as
well as to what this image contains so
this image is basically from a from a
clinical trial and showing some blood
sample or or some vaccine bottles which
is probably the very uh popular image
nowadays because we are living in this
pandemic world so this is the sample
image which I have chosen to read and
then I will load this into the Java
program and then we'll try to write it
back to the file system to our
destination location so this is where my
image is present in the C drive named
with sample.jpg and this is what I've
supplied here so you just need to supply
it in double quotes remember when you
are dealing with Windows File system you
always have to use double forward
slashes which is different if you're
working with a on a Mac machine or
you're working on a Linux system where
only this will work fine so that's a bit
awkward thing which which Windows has
and you have to respect the operating
systems restrictions or way of doing
things so once you have loaded the file
or created the
sample.jpj file object then the next
thing we are going to do is we are going
to create an object of the buffered
image remember we just created a
reference we did not create an object
yet of the preferred image class and now
is the time to do that so we Supply the
width we Supply the height and then we
Supply the type of the image let's go go
to the Constructor of this image to see
what this image type means so this image
type can be basically the type of the
created image which comes from the color
space so whether it's an RGB image or
argb image or BGR image or byte gray
image there are multiple different types
of images in the media space and
whatever type of image you have you need
to basically Supply that image type in
this particular argument so in my case
it was an argb image so I supplied that
particular if you click on this you will
see that currently it's inside Java an
8-bit rgba image basically has a static
constant which is denoted by two you can
read more about this inside the buffered
image class documentation is as well so
once I've supplied that my buffered
image object is ready which has all the
details dimensions and the types of the
image now the next thing is that you
need to fill this image object with the
file so you basically need to read the
file and store the output of this read
operation into the buffering image
object then what will happen that along
with this information whatever is
present here will also be added to the
same buffered image object so to read a
image or a simple a file Java provides
an i o utility which is called image i o
and there is a read method available
which is a static method on this
particular class as you can see I'm
calling the class dot method name here
and then you supply the sample file name
once you have done that then it will
basically be reading the whole image
into a 2d byte array and copying that
over into this buffered image object
once that is done if this particular
line is successfully executed then you
will get this message which will say
reading complete and will try to print
some hash code of the image object and
after that if if there's any exception
this block for example this particular
line May raise an exception of this
particular line May raise an exception
if the file does not exist then you need
to have the IU exception card remember
IO is a checked exception so if you are
using these operations file new file and
image read you need to catch the i o
exception because it's a checked
exception so either you need to catch it
or you need to read through it these are
the only two options you have with the
checked exception so once we have done
all of that if everything goes fine if
everything is Happy till line 35 then we
just return the image object and our
read from file operation will be done
going back to the main method once the
read operation is done the next thing
I'm going to do is writing this image
object to a new destination file so
let's see what is happening in this
write to file method because this is the
method which is responsible for writing
this image to a new destination location
so I've created a public static void
void method inside the same class where
the public static void main method is
present as you know that static methods
can only call other static methods
that's why this has this had to be
static and I'm supplying the same image
object which was returned from the read
operation that goes in as the argument
of this particular method and again I am
using a file object and this time I'm
providing a destination location where
here I would like to write this image so
this is the destination location I've
chosen which is f Drive Java tutorials
folder and the image should be stored
with the name out dot jpg so this is the
location there's already an out.jpg here
so let me just remove it so that we can
observe the output so we create the file
object after that we again use the image
i o utility uh we call our static method
static utility method called Write we
Supply the whole image object we Supply
the image type extension and we Supply
the output location again if I take you
to the signature of this you take the
rendered image you take the format name
which is jpg and the output location so
these are the three things which you
need to supply once you call the write
method on the image i o utility class
image IO is a very handy class and do
remember this class whenever you are
dealing with the image handling
operations it will provide lot of static
convenience methods so we write this
file write this image object to a file
to a destination location and if
everything goes fine in these two lines
we will get this message which will say
writing complete if anything goes wrong
we again catch the exception and the
exception will be printed here that's
all is happening in this particular
program where we are reading from file
and we are writing to the file reading
it from here and writing it on this
particular location so let's run this
program and see if we are able to read
from file successfully and also write it
to the specified location so run as Java
application it's a slightly memory heavy
operation so it takes a bit of time
because the whole image needs to be
loaded into memory be very careful about
that it might heat up your a large
portion of your RAM if the image is too
heavy so here it says reading complete
and then it prints the hash code details
of this particular object and then it
also executed the right to file method
and it said writing complete so just to
show you the reference back again this
is what we read sample.jpg and C drive
and if I go to the F Drive Java
tutorials where I provided the output
location I do see an out.jpg here which
which was not there earlier and if I
double click on this it's exactly the
same image so Java was able to read the
image and render the exact same image by
converting the 2D byte array
representation back to an image exactly
the same for there's no change in this
image so this was a very short and
lightning tutorial for you to show you
how you can use image handling classes
for example the image i o class and the
buffered image class to do basic image
handling operations obviously you can do
more complex operations with it as well
but for the demonstration purpose I've
just kept it simple let's get started
with concurrency Utilities in Java now
concurrency is a huge topic and it's not
possible to cover this into a 10 or 15
minutes tutorials so treat this
particular session as an introductory
session where I will talk about some of
the most relevant classes which you need
to know when you talk about concurrency
we have been talking about this whole
concept of concurrency programming
throughout the thread tutorial as well
and the basic idea is that you would
like to do multiple things at the same
time that's the basic idea now in that
context Java does provide lot of
utilities and packages especially the
java.util.con current package is one of
the most popular package which you need
to use whenever you are dealing with
concurrency programming paradigms in
Java so with that let's have a look at
what does this java.tutil dot concurrent
package contains so broadly it contains
lot of utility classes which can be very
useful for you when you are writing the
concurrent programming code apart from
that it will also provide some basic
ideas around the Locking functionality
and the atomic packages as well when we
talk about locks again we discussed
about locks when we talked about the
whole sync thread synchronization
concept as well and it basically marries
very well with the whole concept of logs
and atomic packages as well Atomic is
again a different topic which is used
for thread safe types basically but
whenever you hear about concurrency
utilities be it in your discussions or
be it in your interviews you will be
seeing a discussion happening around
executors you will hear these terms like
executors executor service future
completable future callable all of these
you will hear the name of all of these
classes quite frequently so we these
classes were first introduced in Java 8
and have been there since then to
support the concurrency programming
Paradigm so I will talk about these
three classes broadly in today's session
and we'll have a look at our
demonstration of these three classes as
well uh let's first talk about executor
technically it's an it's an interface
it's not a class though I said that it's
a class but it's basically an interface
an Executor is basically a very simple
interface which will help you define the
subsystems which you want to which you
would like to create with the help of
threads may be including thread pools or
if you want to do a disk reading and
writing operation in an in synchronous
way or you want to create some sequence
of task Frameworks as well so executor
will provide you a very lightweight
framework to do all of that especially
around thread pooling at asynchronous i
o is is where it shines most because in
your computer you have limited resources
and you would like to uh dedicate a
certain pool of threads for a particular
task or for a particular executor object
so with that on the second class which
we would like to know about is Executor
service an Executor service will provide
a more asynchronous task execution
framework and this is probably the class
which you will be using whenever you're
dealing with asynchronous programming in
Java asynchronous programming basically
means that you submitted a particular
task but you did not wait for it to be
completed you did not hang your process
or your thread for that particular task
to be completed it's very simple it's
very uh easy to relate this to a real
life for example if you are you know
there are times when you do two things
at the same time for example uh let's
take a very very simple example if you
are just boiling milk on on your gas
stove so you put the milk on the gas
stove and then you move out for a couple
of minutes to do some something else for
example maybe checking your mobile for
new emails or or doing some other work
doing maybe just doing some laundry so
uh you are doing you you submitted the
milk boiling task then you moved away
from that task because you know that
this particular task is going to take
some time and you utilize your time
somewhere else that's what we mean by
asynchronous programming and executive
service will provide you with constructs
to create a similar behavior in your
Java program as well so remember about
executor and executor service we will
look at the implementations later where
we can talk about that another
interesting class which I would lot
which I would like to talk about is
future if we have it here yeah so future
is another class which we will be
looking at and future is basically uh to
uh fetch the result of the submitted
task again taking the same knife example
of the milk milk boiling example so it
would be great right if if there is some
mechanism or some alarm which just sets
off the moment the milk is is is boiling
and it's about to be Spilled Out it
would be great to know that in uh that
in advance via some alarm or something
so future provides that kind of a
carrier or that kind of a a holder where
you submitted a particular task you
moved your threads to something else you
did something else and then you can
check with the future object and future
object will tell the status of that
submitted task whether it is completed
or whether it's still in progress once
it is complete then you can fetch the
result of that submitted task based on
with the future object so that's the
concept of future so remember executor
service and future they will work quite
hand in hand because I executor service
will be used to submit the task and
future will be able to fetch the result
of that particular task asynchronously
so that was about a quick Theory you can
read more about it in the documentation
you can see an executed service a future
class what does what does this basically
in this class do uh but to have a look
at or or get a greater sense of this
let's have a look at our demonstration
of it to understand these classes better
so let's move to uh the Eclipse IDE to
look at an example let me close all the
classes and just open a relevant one so
yeah so let's first deal with the
executor interface itself so if I just
minimize this one here I've created a
main class and I've created a public
static white main method and you see two
static methods here executor invoke and
executor service invoke I'm basically
showing you how you can use executor and
executor service so if you're just using
executor then how you would do that is
basically you are going to create a
reference of the executor and then the
executor needs a basically an Executor
object because it's an executed
reference so you need to supply an
Executor object so either you can supply
an inner class right here or you can
call you can create a executed type of
class which I've created here which is
called color class so I've created a
class called caller which implements the
executor type and execute the moment you
write implements executor it will force
you to override the execute method and
inside the execute method you are going
to run your own thread so this is how
the current thread or the executor's own
thread will be running so once you have
done the initialization then you can
call the execute method on the executor
class remember you got this object so
you can call the executor execute method
on the executor object here and inside
this you can provide this particular
Lambda function implementation which is
going to ask you what exactly you want
to do when I run this particular thread
so when I run this thread one Java runs
this particular thread what do you want
Java to do that's something which you
will provide here so this is how you can
use it's a very simple example like I
said
this if I build a more complex example
it will take a lot of time and lot of
other con Concepts to cover so treat
this as an introductory session and you
can basically try to run a very simple
example of this writing whatever complex
logic you want to write while the thread
is running and put that into this
execute similarly if you if you want to
use executed service for doing the
asynchronous operations then it will
follow the same way but there are some
differences along the way as well so
this is the method which is showing the
executor service implementation or the
way of using executed service so again I
create a reference of executor service
and then here you see I'm saying
executors dot new fixed thread pool with
a size of 10. so that's the power of
executor service it is going to create a
pool of threads dedicated to itself to
do the tasks whichever are written
inside here so whatever you write here
these thread pool will be utilized to
execute that particular task you can
assign the size of the thread pool based
on how many threads you need there are
multiple static utility methods like
there is one new fixed thread pool which
I've used but if you just do Ctrl enter
you will see cached thread pool a single
thread execution a new work stealing
pool so like I mentioned there are a lot
of classes interesting classes here
which you can use for Simplicity I've
just used a fixed thread pool here once
you get the executor service object then
here you called execute but here you
will be calling the submit method and
then the drill goes exactly the same way
that you write the Lambda function
implementation inside here basically the
functional interface implementation and
you provide your own implementation code
which you would like to run whenever you
call the run method whenever this
executor service calls the run method on
that particular thread you can actually
go to the submit method and you will see
it accepts a runnable it basically
accepts a thread object so whatever you
write inside this particular code will
be the public void run implementation of
that particular thread class if you
don't if you don't remember how
trainable works please go back to my
threading tutorial and watch that
whereas explained the runnable interface
and the run method in detail so that's
what we are doing here so this is for
executor and this is for executor
service so let's run this program and
yes I mean nothing because I'm not doing
anything much apart from just doing six
outs here and that's what you see here
the executor example and the executor
service exam so this was about executor
and executor service now let's deal with
another interesting class of of called
future which I said that I will also
talk about so for that I have created a
separate demo because it deserves a
separate demo it's a very interesting
class so let me just make it full screen
yeah so I've created a class called
future demo which has a public static
void main method and again I'm doing
this in this executor service
initialization but this time I'm using a
new single thread executor now what does
this do this this will basically create
an Executor which will use a single
worker thread operating from an
unbounded queue remember even if this
single thread terminates due to let's
say a failure during the execution and
before the before the graceful shutdown
a new one will automatically be spawned
and will take its place if the execution
is still pending so that's the power of
single worker thread from an unbounded
queue that's what I've used here based
on your use case you can use other ones
as well like I mentioned earlier then uh
I have the executor service object with
me and similar to the previous example
I'm going to call the submit method and
inside the submit method I need to
provide the runnable class runable
interfaces implementation and that
implementation will basically be of the
public void run method and this is what
I want to do in my run method where I am
sleeping the thread for 10 seconds
thread.sleep method takes millisecond
values as the parameter so this is 10
000 which means 10 seconds so I'm
sleeping this thread or pausing this
thread for 10 seconds and then returning
a string called completed this is what I
am doing in the executor service dot
submit implementation the result of it
is going to be a future object the
remember the result of the submit task
is going to be a future object so I
store that future reference here and
then at line 20 I'm using the same
feature of future object to ask Java to
check if this task is done and the way
you do that is just by calling is done
so till the time there is a negation
condition till the time the task is
still in progress because this main
feature is not done because I've put a
negation then just print this is out
where you say the task is still in
progress It's still not complete and you
pause this particular thread remember
this was a different thread if you you
pause this particular thread for 500
millisecond or basically half a second
and you again check this condition if
it's still not done you print this again
pause for half a second again check this
till the time feature dot is done
becomes true When Future dot is done
becomes true that means that this
particular task is completed now you see
I mean generally when we execute the
programs the execution happens sequently
sequentially that after line 17 the
control will automatically flow to line
20 and before the control can reach line
20 everything above line 17 has to be
completed that's that's basically
synchronous programming for you but when
you talk about asynchronous programming
using the power of executor service and
future objects we can do something here
which will go into a separate thread and
then you can continue your execution
here so this can be in a different
method altogether where you submit
something and this is basically checking
the status of this task understand this
very well this is very important concept
that it's not as it's though it's a
sequential execution after line 17 line
20 is getting executed but line 20 is
not waiting for everything above line 17
to be finished it will continue That's
The Power of asynchronous programming so
here we are checking this and once the
feature dot future dot is done says true
then we say task completed we and then
you probably would like to fetch the
result of this particular task right and
for that future provides a method called
future dot get this is going to pick the
future object State and whatever you are
returning from here will be returned
here and then I'm printing the result so
if everything went fine this result
should say completed because that's what
I'm returning from this future object
and always remember to shut down your
executor service to release the thread
pool which you created here I've also
put a catch block here because I'm using
the third dot Sleep Method which will
ask you to handle an interrupted
exception and then there is an Executor
service exception which is execution and
a timeout exception as well there are
other interesting methods as well on the
future class future object sorry which
is like future dot cancel where you can
cancel explicitly a future task which is
currently in progress you can check the
status of it by calling is done which I
have used here which you can also call
is cancel to check if the user or some
other process explicitly canceled the
execution of the submission of the
executor service task so hope this is
you are able to understand the flow of
it that these block and these block will
program will execute them but they will
run in different threads so let's see
what happens now I'm going to run this
particular program and if I bring this
here you see the task still in progress
keeps getting called so we submitted the
task here and now this block is getting
executed this block kept getting
executed so this task did not finish
right the thread.sleep was this this
thread this whole thread was sleeping
for 10 seconds but line 20 did not wait
for 10 seconds it continued execution
and it kept checking the future object
10 times at least or till the whole 10
second sleep was taken away and one once
that once this thread woke up it
returned completed feature dot is done
became true and it came out and it said
task completed so that's what we get
here and at the end in the result you
get completed which is which is what you
returned from here so this is the power
of asynchronous programming please like
I mentioned please do read about more
about these classes and how they work
and what is the Paradigm of asynchronous
programming it does make debugging a bit
harder at times but it's a very
interesting concept to be used in
concurrent applications let's get
started with regular expressions or
regex in Java you may hear people
calling it as as regex or regex doesn't
matter you can call it anything as as
you want till the time you have the
concept understood in the right way I'll
just call it as regex so when we talk
about regex let's understand why do we
need them and what are how Java actually
provides support for that so the basic
idea behind regular Expressions is is to
find a pattern in a in a Text corpus if
you have lot of strings available if you
have any kind of text any kind of string
and if you would like to find a
particular pattern saying okay does this
whole text paragraph contains any
character or contains any number or
contains any special characters or
contains characters after numbers or
numbers after characters so if you would
like to find those kind of patterns in
in your Text corpus then you can then
that concept is called called regular
expression finding and Java provides the
support for that particular regular
expression finding through a package
called java.util dot regex package so
this is the package which you would need
to use when you want to do any kind of
regular expression finding in the text
now you may want you may be thinking
that why do I need to use this I already
have the string handling methods right
you can do substring you can find a
particular character in the string Etc
but that is limited because it only and
only provides string Methods ways to
manipulate and find and replace strings
but regex is generic you can literally
find any kind of character in your
string it can be a special character it
can be a square bracket it can be a
multiply sign it can be a divide sign it
can be like I said integer uh capital
letters small case letters so any kind
of pattern you would like to find
java.util.regex can be used to find that
kind of pattern now this package is very
interesting and it provides lots of
classes and again this is a very very
very big topic and very complex topic so
we will just scratch the surface of it
and like I always say whenever you would
like to read more about it go back and
read the documentation currently the
documentation I've opened is for version
8 but when you are reading it you can go
for the latest Java Edition uh
documentation so with that let's talk
about some of the interesting classes
which we will be dealing with and we
must know when we talk about regex in
Java so I already explained what are
regular Expressions uh let's go to the
interesting classes the first class
which we need to know about is the
patent class so pattern class or an
object of the pattern class will
basically be representing a compiled
regular expression so you write your
regular expression in a certain way
regular expression has its own language
I would say to write the pattern for
example if you would like to write a
pattern saying that find check if this
particular text paragraph has the
characters first then the integers then
the characters then this particular
special character so that is your
pattern you write that pattern then you
need to compile that pattern to compile
that pattern you can use the pattern
class this this class generally does not
provide any kind of public Constructors
to you so you cannot initialize the
pattern object explicitly but to create
a pattern you first you need to
basically call the static methods static
method named as compile so compile is
the method which you need to use to
compile your regular expression which
will then return the pattern object once
you have compiled your written your
pattern and your compile your pattern
the next class which you need to know
about is the matcher class matcher class
will provide that particular engine
framework which will understand and
interpret the pattern and then we'll try
to find that pattern on the text
paragraph which you are supplying and it
will result in true or false if it finds
that pattern it will say true if it's
not finding the pattern it will say
false so that's the basic idea so you
need to you need to know about the
pattern class and you need to know about
the matcher class so so it also does not
the matching class also does not provide
any kind of public Constructors and you
obtain a matcher object by calling the
matcher method on the pattern object so
once you created a pattern object just
call the matcher on that particular
object and that will get you unmatched
object and it then you can use that
object to find the patterns in that
particular Text corpus there is also a
dedicated exception which is called
pattern syntax exception which will be
thrown whenever you have written the
regular expression syntax incorrectly
like I said it has its it has its own
language so you need to write the
expression in a way regular expressions
are supposed to be written and supposed
to be understood I will touch upon that
in a while but that's that's the basic
idea about the three classes now when
when you would like to find a pattern it
can be a string pattern it can be some
characters it can be some predefined
characters some quantifiers you can also
create subgroups within the regular
expression so there is a like I said
there's a tons of functionality which is
available in this particular concept and
we will just cover some of the relevant
ones or just just run through some of
these Concepts and then I will switch to
a demonstration for example if we talk
about the string literals then you can
do the string matching for example if
you want to find this particular word or
this pattern this is just a text pattern
right so if you would like to find this
particular text pattern in the text
string then you can write this
particular text pattern as a string
pattern inside the pattern object so
that's that's about the string literals
now let's move to some interesting ones
like like meta characters and The Meta
characters are very interesting because
they have a special meaning for example
if you write your regular expression
like this where you say cat and then you
say dot then when you are applying this
particular regular expression to find
the match into a string it is only going
to find the match for c a t it is not
going to find the match for cat dot
because dot is a meta character in
regular expression it has a special
meaning it it does not mean dot but it
has a special meaning and that special
meaning basically means that even though
the dot is not present it will basically
mean that after cat it can be any
character so the meta character dot
means any character which is why you see
this snatch succeeds because it will
search for this pattern which it matches
and after that it can be any character
it doesn't care so even if it's s or D
or whatever it will say true because c a
t was found a match so dot means any
character after the pattern you have
specified similarly there are lot of
other characters special characters or
meta characters like the ones which have
been listed here question mark Star Plus
dot on and all of these have their own
dedicated special meaning they are not
your your normal uh arithmetic operators
or other operators they have their
special meaning when you are dealing
with meta characters so do read about
them in detail and I will be using a bit
of meta characters in the example as
well then the character classes are also
very interesting similar to the example
which I told you before if you want to
find a particular string or a particular
integer into a into a Text corpus then
you can use the character class patterns
for example you just put a square
brackets and you write ABC this means
that it will try to find exactly ABC in
the string if you put a cap in front of
ABC then it will try to match any
character or find any character except a
b or c so it's a negation similarly if
you specify small A to Z and capital A
to Z it means any character can be there
between small case A to Z and capital
case A to Z A to Z inclusive similarly
you can provide specific ranges like a
through D or M through P so only the
characters which will match the union of
this condition will be returning true
and rest of the uh if that if this
particular pattern is violated then you
will get false so similarly there are
you can build lot of complex combination
and permutations with these Special beta
characters and character classes do read
about these in detail if you are curious
to know about it and there is tons of
materials available on this on internet
which you can read about to learn more
about similarly there are predefined
character classes as well dot is
something which which I already
explained which means any character then
you can use slash D to find a digit in a
particular string or a particular Text
corpus slash capital D is for non-digit
or you can use the classic negation
condition as well slash S is for a white
space character slash capital S is for a
non-white space character word non-word
so there are a lot of different examples
so I think by now you would have built a
decent understanding of what I'm trying
to tell you is that you can specify
these patterns compile them and then use
the matcher so let's move to a very
simple demonstration it's not a complex
example but very simple example just to
get the point across so I'm creating a
regex string here and this is the
pattern I've specified I'm saying any
character star means any number of
characters so it can be anything here
then the string the the pattern expects
an alphabetical string or alphabetical
section after that the alphabetical
section should be followed by a
numerical section and after the
numerical section again it can be any
character so this is my pattern I create
a simple string with this regex pattern
and like I mentioned in the
documentation you call pattern dot
compile to compile the regular
expression so I compile the regular
expression I get the pattern object and
after again as per the documentation it
said that you can call the matcher
method on the pattern object to get a
matcher object so I say pattern dot
matcher and I provide my string on which
I want to test it so I've just put a
random string where there are some
integers then there is some alphabets
and then again there are some integers
once you have got the matcher object
just call matcher dot find this will
return a Boolean where you can test
whether the uh the matcher found a hit
in the Text corpus or not if it found a
match the match found will be true and
if it didn't found the find the match
you will get a false value in this
result so with that understanding let's
run this program so I get the output
match found why did I get that because I
said that start with anything so it
started with anything I don't care what
it is it's an integer or any special
character I don't care after that there
should be some alphabets so there are
some alphabets and right after alphabets
there should be some numbers so again
there are some numbers and after that
there can be any character 0 or more
characters so there is nothing here
that's why you see a match found Let's
do an interesting test here let me do
this I Put A to Z again here so now I'm
saying start with anything have
alphabets have numbers and again after
numbers you should have some alphabet
which is not the case here because you
start with something you have alphabets
you have numbers and after numbers the
string ends there is nothing after that
so let's see what happens now we get a
match not found because this particular
pattern when got compiled and got
applied on this particular string did
not find find the string following the
regex pattern which you have specified
so this is a very simple example to show
you how you can build patterns you can
use groups Concepts as well to group the
patterns it can get very very complex
and very very nasty so use them very
wisely very carefully uh and do read
about the documentation and other
examples which I talked about to get
more understanding and more comfortable
with regex let's get started with nio
packages in Java now let's first
understand why why do we need this
package and where we'll be using this
package let's talk about the where first
you can use the nio package to read from
a file or write to a file now let's talk
about the why because the obvious
question will be that we already have
the i o package in Java right where you
can where you can use the classes from
that particular package to read from a
file or write to a file then why do we
need an another package doing exactly
the same thing as nio so the basic
reason for launching the java.nio
package was providing the
multi-threading capabilities to the io
library and we could not do this in the
existing IO library because we had to
probably rewrite and change the
functionality of it that's why Java
created a new library called new package
called java.nio package and this package
is basically uh I mean if you if you
understand what nio means here generally
as per the popular perception it means
non-blocking I O that you don't want to
block your threads while you are reading
to a file or writing to a file
classically nio meant networking i o but
as per the popular perception people
know is that no it has non-blocking IO
so the basic idea is because whenever
you are read reading a file or writing
to a file the thread gets blocked until
the whole file is written or until the
whole file is read so the nio package
provides an improvement over that it
provides an improvement in a way that
you can read the file into a different
thread but at the same time move on to
another thread and and writes to a file
so you get this multi-threading
capabilities and non-blocking
capabilities out of the box from the
classes provided by java.nio package so
that's the brief about this package now
some of the popular classes which you
will be dealing with and some of the
concepts which you need to know about
NIU package are buffers and channels
these this is probably the core concept
of the whole nio package of how channels
and buffers work so let's say you are
trying to read something then the read
operation will be happening from the
channel into the buffer and similarly
the right operation will be happening in
the reverse way which means to the
channel from the buffer so that's how
the buffer and channel work together
that whenever you are trying to write
something you have to first open a
channel create a buffer and then you can
read from the channel into the buffer
and similarly when you're writing to the
buffer you again have to go via the
channel route so channel is that route
basically buffer is basically just a
plane container for the data and channel
is basically represent entering the
connection to the entities which are
capable of Performing the IU operation
so think of channels as as a pipe a
channel literally basically if you if
you understand the English meaning of
Channel that's exactly what we mean by
here that it provides just a means to an
end it provides sort of a wire to the
buffer and then you also have selectors
and selection Keys classes which
together with selection channels work to
provide the non-blocking io
functionality there are some other apis
uh interesting apis as well like car set
and some more but I will not go into the
detail of that because if you know about
buffers and channels and selectors then
we will be able to figure out what
exactly we would like to do with this I
would also like to talk a bit more about
the buffer class so if you go to the
buffer classes operations the popular
operations you will see there will be
the read operation which is for reading
the files basically or reading the
content of the file this works on the
byte stream concept first of all so to
read the bytes from the file you will
call the read method there's also a very
interesting method called flip which I
will be using which makes a buffer ready
for the new sequence of operations so
once you have done something and you
want to let's say you read a particular
file and you have come to the end of the
file now you would like to reset the
buffer and go back to the beginning of
the file then you can use the flip
method for that particular piece to to
bring the current position back to the
position to the zero index or to the
starting of the file so that's about
read and flip and we will have a look at
some of the other methods and there are
a lot of interesting classes in this nio
package do read a read about the
documentation and check out the other
methods as well to learn more about this
package but the basics are like I said
channels buffers some methods of the
buffers and there's also a path class
which is used to basically provide a
particular path to a directory which I
will not be covering in this example but
something good to know so with that
understanding let's move to a an example
and understand how we can work around
with this and IO package so for for that
I have prepared an example where I will
be writing a reading from a file and
then writing to a file so I have a main
method here the first section here
basically is about reading from a file
and the second section is about writing
to a file so let's go through all of
both of these sections one by one to
understand what is happening so in the
read section I use the file input stream
class from the io package I'm still not
using the paths class here just to show
you that both two both of them still can
work together if you want to use the old
constructs so use the same file input
construct to read a file called
source.txt which is present at this
particular location in my directory and
this source.txt has has just a one line
of text nothing more so I I basically
create the file input stream object and
then I create a channel because we are
dealing with files so you create a file
Channel if you're dealing with network
socket then you might have a socket
channel so that's also something which
you need to know about that this nio
package is is generated can be used for
any kind of communication of reading and
writing not specifically to file
handling so we create a file Channel
object here by calling file input stream
dot get channel it's that simple once
you call that you will get a reference
or the object basically of the file
Channel then the next thing is to create
the buffer like you mentioned that
channels and the buffer are the two main
tools through which you work with an NIU
Library so we create a byte buffer and
we allocate some starting size to it
just some some threshold size so you can
put it any number which you think is
practical for your file and for the use
case here I've put just one zero two
four bytes or one megabyte because my
file is pretty small so I just put that
and initialize that read buffer and then
I call read Channel dot read operation
so the file Channel object you created
you just call the read method on this
particular Channel and Supply the buffer
and then it is going to read the file
via the channel into the buffer and this
read method is going to return a result
to denote if the file was written
successfully or not and just printing a
printing assist out here just a bare
once it's out nothing new here so this
section will be used to read a file so
let's see if I can read the file
successfully and then we'll move to the
right section so I go to run as Java
application yeah it says file rate
successfully and it read 27 bytes it
means that there were total of 27 bytes
in my in my file which had a single line
of text so it read all of that and it it
completed the execution now let's move
to the right section and I can comment
the read section because we have covered
that so here I am again creating a file
output stream object because I need to
write something so again using the same
construct of the io package I have
covered previously in the previous
sessions once you have the file output
stream object created the next thing is
to create a channel so I again create a
file Channel but this time it's the
right channel I again create a buffer
which is the right buffer allocate some
size to it then this is the string which
I want to write to this particular file
so my file my destination file will be
called test dot txt will be present in
this particular location and this file
should have this string written if this
whole operation goes successfully that's
my end goal so to do that I say write
buffer dot put and whatever string you
have created just call get bytes on it
and you get a bytes representation of
the whole string so that's what I've
done here because this put method
expects byte because if you go inside
this it expects a byte array so that's
what I'm supplying here and providing
the the bytes array by on the string by
calling message dot get byte or any
string object dot get bytes will get
your byte array once you've done that
then I'm calling the flip method
remember I talked about the slip method
to basically reset the index that's
something which you need to do in this
particular case so that the index goes
back to the initial position and the
buffer can be written successfully to a
file uh to a channel basically so once
the buffer is is com has completed its
operation then I can write the buffer to
the channel and once that is done then
if those if these operations went
successfully then I will see a file
called test.txt in this particular
directory currently there is no desk.txt
in this directory you can see there are
just three files but there is no
test.txt so let's run this program so it
says file written successfully which was
the last sys out at line 28 but let's
also see what is happening in the
directory so now I see a desktop txt
popping up here it's a 1kb file and if I
double click on this I see the same
string which is which say this is a test
string which is the same string which I
supplied here so you can see you can use
the nio packages to do the file read and
write and much much more than just read
and write using the nio package but this
is just to get get the point across that
this can be done using the nio or the
non-blocking i o package as well so that
you get maximum performance on your
machine while you deal with file IO
operations let's get started with Java
beans so we have been creating Java
classes and creating objects of those
Java classes to work and manipulate
transfer data call methods create
properties Etc and Java beans just use
that as the groundwork to create a
specification first of all let's
understand that Java beans is just a
standard it is just a specification
which has been provided by by Java to be
followed while you are implementing
production grade or Enterprise grade
applications so it's just a pure
specification set of Standards if you
want to read more about this please go
to this particular link which is written
here I mean if you just Google Java be
in Spec Oracle then you will be able to
find this particular link you will see a
download option here if you go here you
will get these two specification
documents option so you can just accept
the license agreement and click on this
particular beans 0 1 1 0 1 PDF F and you
can read about the whole Java Bean
specification I have already downloaded
this particular PDF which is opened in
this tab and if you go to the TOC here
it's an official Sun microsystem white
paper basically and if you read about
this this is going to explain the whole
Java beans API specifications it's going
to specify the core components of the
Java beans component architecture so
it's a specification let's understand
that very well if you go to the table of
contents let's go to the interesting one
which says what is exactly a bean or a
Java Bean so a Java Bean is basically a
reusable software component that can be
manipulated in any visual IDE like
eclipse or IntelliJ or netbeans Etc so
technically a Java Bean is just a Java
class but that Java class should follow
three main properties the first property
is that that Java class should have
Getters and Setters to access the
properties second property is that that
that Java class should have a public no
argument Constructor so that anybody can
create an object of it and third is that
the Java class should implement
serializable the reason in Java beans
specify these three conditions which I
said so let's talk about the third one
where we are talking we are saying that
it should be implementing serializable
interface why is that it's because our
Java Bean would be required to be
exported between applications may be
required to be returned to a database or
to a file system or to be converted into
an XML or a Json document sent over the
network again being deserialized so this
will be moving across a lot because
that's what we mean by reusable multiple
different software components and
applications might be reusing that bean
again and again and that beat needs to
travel across and to enable that that
beam has to be serializable because if
we can't serialize it you just cannot
transport that object to another
application education it's just not
possible this is how Java has been so
that's why you need to implement
serializable you need to have a public
no argument Constructor and you need to
have Getters and Setters to access your
properties you can actually read more
about this if you scroll down it will
also talk about the difference between
beans and class libraries remember not
class but class libraries and here it
explains what I just said that a Java
Bean can have properties it can have
events and it can have methods so
properties are nothing but the normal
attributes which you create inside Java
class nothing fancy the same attributes
are named as properties for example you
may have a foreground property and then
you can have a method which is just a
normal Java method which can be called
from other applications or from an
environment and by default all of the
beans public methods will be exported by
exported I meant when you export this
when you serialize and Export this
object all the beans public methods will
be exported by default but then a beam
can choose to export only a subset of
its methods if it wants to a bean can
also have events and events basically
provide a way for one object to notify
other objects that something has
happened so something similar to the uh
to the producer consumer example or the
producer consumer pattern where you can
notify other objects threads also have
this particular pattern where a thread
can notify other threads that it has
completed its task and other threads can
start so uh so this is so that's the
property behind event where something
has occurred and then the object can
tell other objects it's that that
something has occurred so that they can
react to that particular event so these
are the three main uh traits which are
properties events and methods uh you can
read more about this particular white
paper I will not go into the details
because it's a long white paper but it's
a very well written white paper which
will give you a very good understanding
of how Java Bean specification was
written what was the thought process
behind it so coming back to the code if
you want to just write it it can be very
simple to write just write any class and
say implements serializable so it will
ask you to provide a CL version YouTube
ID so you can write this here then you
can create your attributes as normal
private attributes you can create public
methods to access and manipulate these
attributes in the forms of Getters and
Setters so these are the public methods
to to access and manipulate these
attributes here we have a parameterized
Constructor which will not be required
or which should not be there when you
are creating a Java Bean it should just
be like this because when we talk about
the public no arcs Constructor as we
discussed in the very first lectures
that you do not need to provide the
default Constructor Java will
automatically provide a default
Constructor for every class so you don't
need to write something like this it's
just not needed because you can write it
but it has no value attached it has no
meaning because this is something exact
this kind of code is already generated
by Java compiler when it compiles this
particular class so a public default no
argument Constructor implementing
serializable private properties and
public methods and you can have
additional event methods as well which I
talked about just when we were going
through the white paper and that's all
pretty much what a Java Bean is so you
can see it's it's just a Java class but
some additional specifications which a
Java class has to follow to be called as
a Java beam let's get started with
spring framework so spring framework is
the most popular web application
framework available out there today and
all of the big companies from Netflix to
what not use spring framework to build
the modern day Java applications so
before we go any further let's
understand why do we need a framework so
let's understand this with the help of a
diagram so let me just open a blank
paint page and let me show you what I
mean by a framework and why do we need
this so we build simple applications so
far but if you have to build uh
Enterprise grade web application you
will have a front end probably where you
will have what you see in the browser so
you will have the HTML the JavaScript or
or any other Java Enterprise Edition
classes like GSP servlet Etc then you
will have a backend where your Java
classes are present which contains the
business logic so the business logic and
then you have a database where you have
the you store the basic basically the
whole data so you have these three
different layers we also call this a
three tier architecture so you cannot
build all of this by just using the core
Java classes which we talked about you
need to do more Integrations you need to
use more different programming languages
and Concepts to build a complete
Enterprise grid application and if you
try to build all of this by yourself
then it's going to take a lot of time
and lot of effort that's why we have
frame Works which basically create
provide the structure to create these
three layers so that's why we have this
Frameworks and in the Frameworks spring
is the most popular framework it
provides the structure to write all
these these three layers one of the
reasons I did not talk about the the
Java Enterprise Edition Technologies
like servlets and gsps because nobody
works on them today even if you learn
about servlet it's good to know the
conceptual overview of servlets but
nobody today builds applications on jsps
and servlets that's the reason I did not
talk about it because today we have
sophisticated front-end Frameworks like
angularjs or react.js or amberjs and
whatnot and it is iterating at a very
faster speed so there is literally
practically no need for a Java developer
today to learn about GSP because I can
bet you on that you can take it in
return from me nobody is going to build
the JSP app based applications in 2021
everybody is going to use some sort of
front-end framework to build that and
then you have a backend in the back end
you have the exact core Java classes
like I just explained so you will be
using the Java beans and you will be
basically using the pure Java concepts
of Collections and and Etc to write the
backend logic using the Java classes and
then you will need a jdbc connection to
write through a database as well so you
would need a database as well and spring
provides connectors and specifications
to support all of these three layers
that's the reason so generally when you
talk about a web application let's talk
about web application because Java
primarily is used in web applications so
in a web application you basically see a
browser window where you load a
particular page but what happens behind
the scene this browser has some HTML and
some js maybe and this code is basically
calling some endpoint this endpoint is
present in the backend layer so this
endpoint is present in the backend layer
that endpoint transfers the control to
the business layer where you have your
core business logic written and then the
business layer transfers the control to
the data layer or some people also call
it dial layer this dial layer then talks
to the database that's how a web
application works and that's what that's
the architecture you will mostly be
following whenever you are building any
Enterprise grid application in any
organization so spring provides support
for all of these parts this obviously is
written by angular and react and other
Frameworks but this is this whole
section is basically presented or
supported by spring so with that let's
understand a bit more about spring
framework so if you go to the spring
official website it talks about some of
the value propositions spring is used
heavily like I said it's used everywhere
it's very flexible framework there are a
couple of Concepts which spring provides
which is around inversion of control and
dependency injection and I will talk
about these Concepts in a while when
we'll talk more about the Springs
components it makes uh it's quite
productive and quite fast as well so
it's very fast to build application on
on Spring it has a whole dedicated
security module as well so it's quite
secure by Design and the spring
Community is huge so you can find lot of
support on internet let's learn bit more
about the Spring's core components or
core Technologies so if you talk about
the spring core components these are the
Spring's core components so you have a
testing module you have you have a core
module first of all inside the Techno in
the core components you have a core
module which has ioc containers
resources events I'll talk a bit about
that it has a it has its own testing
component so it provides very good
support for testing applications it has
a data access component the data access
component is used to provide connections
utilities to the database because like I
mentioned your application will be
talking to the database and spring
provides a complete dedicated component
to be used whenever you are dealing
whenever you are talking to the database
it also provides a web servlet component
to provide support for spring MVC which
I will be covering in the next session
web sockets and stomp and messaging
Frameworks Etc it also supports reactive
or asynchronous programming if you want
to do that it provides lot of
integration capabilities in the
integration modules if you want to do
JMS or jmx or email or task scheduling
Etc and it also provides language
support to support internationalized
internationalization of the applications
so it it has lot of different components
but we will focus on this core component
which is of the interest here so let's
talk about that the first thing which
you need to know about spring is its
support for inversion of control and it
provides that support by creating an
inversion of control container what do
we mean by inversion of control the
basic idea is let me take any random
example and I will be able to
communicate the idea behind this so
let's go to any simple example which I
have already covered let's go to Method
calling for example so we had a student
class we created a student class simple
student class 3 properties Constructor
and public Getters and Setters and then
I created a main class and I initialized
the student object so to the
responsibility of creating the student
object lies with the student class
itself student class have to be
explicitly initialized to be having an
object of the student so this creates a
problem because when you are dealing
with uh Enterprise grade Frameworks you
might need to create lot of objects on
the fly whenever the end point is
talking to the business layer if I take
the reference of this architecture if
the endpoint is talking to the business
layer classes business layer classes are
talking to the data access layer classes
so when the business layer classes needs
to talk to the data access layer classes
the data access layer classes needs to
have an object because the communication
happens between objects only so who
creates those objects if every time the
data access object has been has been
called and if we provide if we pass that
responsibility to the Dow class to
create the object or every time the
endpoint talks to the business class we
ask the business layer to create the
objects it becomes a lot of painful
process because every time you will be
doing this new student everywhere you
need a student object which is very
painful process so what spring says it
says okay invert the control of creating
the object so let's not give the
responsibility of creating the object to
the class let's give that responsibility
to the framework so the framework will
be responsible for creating the objects
of a class and it's not the class who
will be responsible for creating its own
objects so generally outside the
framework a class is responsible for
getting its object but with spring
spring inverts this responsibility
that's why we call it inversion of
control the control is inverted it's
reversed and now it's the framework's
responsibility to create the objects you
will also hear about a concept called
dependency injection lot in context of
iuc and dependency injection is an
implementation of the iuc concept so
using Springs dependency injection
mechanism you can inject the object of
any class into any class once you do
that spring dependency is going to use
the inversion of control concept and
create the object that's about ioc and
Di or dependency injection then the
other modules like resources will
provide a way to refer different files
and properties if you want to then you
have a validation module as well which
will provide different validation
constraints because once you receive the
data you might need to run lot of
validation right and writing the
validation by yourself can be very
painful so it provides a validation
framework as well by providing the
validator interface you can use this
particular framework to write the
validation rules checking the name not
empty Etc similarly it also supports an
expression language if you want to use
that so the expression language support
is wide very wide in fact you can create
an expression parser and can do the
expression language evaluation using the
a spring expression language similarly
it also provides support for aspect
oriented programming now again all these
concepts of validation and spring
expression language and resource support
the you probably would need hours of
reading to learn about these Concepts
and I'm just running through them just
to tell you about these Concepts and do
read about why do you need resources why
do you want to do validation why do you
need an expression language what is
aspect oriented programming read about
all of those Concepts because they are
not related to Java they are generic
Concepts which will be applicable to any
programming language so any Enterprise
application you build in any programming
language you would need to do the
validation you would need to do the
resource reference management you would
need to have an expression language you
would need to have aspect oriented
programming support so this is just to
tell you that that Java does provide an
aop or aspect oriented programming
support as well and it has lot of apis
available for that along with that it
also provides very good logging
capabilities because you definitely need
to log all the actions which the
framework or your objects are taking so
this was a very quick lightning overview
about spring I understand it's not
possible to cover all the concept of a
framework as sophisticated and as smart
as spring in in a 10 to 15 minutes
lecture so treat this as an introduction
session and like I said read more about
all of these components I just explained
the core because this is this is sort of
the main building block of spring
framework and then you have other
supporting uh components as well so do
check out the documentation there are
tons of examples available in fact in
the springs official website itself if
you go to the spring guide section if
you go to the uh learn any go to the
guide section there are awesome getting
started and topical guides and tutorials
available so for example how to build a
restful web service how to schedule
tasks how to consume a restful web
service how to build a simple Java
project with Maven how to upload files
with string how to do messaging with
redis which is basically a caching
framework how to do messaging using
spring to Rabbit and queue rabbit and
queue is a messaging framework so there
are tons of examples available here very
good documentation a very robust
documentation do check out the examples
to learn more about this let's get
started with MVC and the implementation
of MVC using spring so before we go any
further let's first understand what do
we mean by an MVC application so in the
previous lectures I discussed about the
three-tier application where you had a
presentation layer you had a business
layer and then you had a database layer
which is talking to the database and
that's how we built a three-tier
application which can also evolve into
an anterior application but when when
the web development started the most
popular concept which came out was
MVC m stands for model V stands for View
and C stands for controller so the idea
was that these three components together
can render a web application and how
they render the web application is
basically that the controller is going
to receive the request which is coming
from the web browser then the controller
will have the knowledge of where the
business Logic for that particular
request will be residing so the
controller is going to invoke the model
the corresponding model which is
required to execute the business logic
of the request and the controller will
also have the knowledge of what response
page to be sent back to the user so we
are talking about the response page here
not response remember that because it's
a web application so the model view
controller architecture basically was
designed to keep in mind that you have a
web application where a request is
coming from and you need to process some
business logic and then you need to
return back with a page response which
is going to be displayed on the web
browser of the client machine so that's
why we had these three components as
model view and controller controller
taking the the request then finding the
right model for it which can execute the
business logic and then also finding the
right view for it which can render the
business logic processed by the model so
that's a quick overview about model view
controller or MVC architecture do read
about it in detail to understand how
this works but like I mentioned that MVC
the most popular MVC implementation is
provided by Spring spring is the most
popular MVC framework and the Way Spring
implements it is something which I have
drawn already here so let's understand
how this works so first the request
comes from the web browser and spring
has a a very first welcome servlet which
is called dispatcher servlet any request
which is coming to the spring enabled
web application will first hit
dispatcher servlet and once the request
comes to the dispatcher servlet the
dispatcher servlet has all the knowledge
of all the controllers of all the view
resolvers which I will talk about in a
while and of all the views as well it
also has knowledge about Handler
mappings which again I will just discuss
now so the basic premise is that
dispatcher servlet is the component
which has knowledge about literally
everything happening in your application
and that's why dispatcher's servlet is
the first servlet or the first component
which receives your web request so once
the request comes here first of all it
looks at the path and finds out the
right Handler for it the right
controller for it and the way it does
that by using the Handler mapping
component or Handler mapping logic which
is provided out of the box by Spring
framework so the Handler mapping logic
will tell the dispatcher servlet which
particular controller is going to
process the request which is coming
because every request will have a
different controller return so whatever
the type of request is whatever the path
of the request is based on that the
dispatcher servlet is going to find a
particular controller once the
controller is found like I mentioned
earlier the controller will have
knowledge about the right model to
invoke for that particular request model
is nothing but basically a Java class
holding the business Logic for this
particular request so it will invoke
that Java class and get all the business
logic processed and then it is going to
return a model and view object view is
here simply pointing to the UI response
which you are going to send back to the
user it can be a GSP page it can be an
HTML page it can be any other view
technology so anything which is which is
used to render a web application on a
web page is View and controller is going
to send both the model and view
information back to the dispatcher
servlet the dispatcher servlet will take
the view part of it and go to another
component which is again provided by
Spring which is called view resolver the
view resolver will have the knowledge to
see which particular actual JSP or
template to invoke for the view value
coming from the controller So based on
the value which is written by the
controller a view resolver is going to
return the right page mapping and once
the dispatcher servlet knows the page
mapping it is just going to invoke that
page by calling the view component so
dispatcher servlet Handler mapping
controller View resolver and view these
five components together help render a
web MVC application in the spring
framework so that was about the theory
of how spring works now let's move on to
a example to understand how this works
in action so here I have already built a
spring MVC application and if you're
wondering how to build that there's an
easy way to do that using spring
initializer and that's also the
recommended way actually if you go to
the documentation of spring you will see
that it recommends creating a new
project from scratch using the spring
initializer utility which is provided by
Spring out of the box so just go to web
a web browser and type
start.spring.io you will get this page
we where you can specify what type of
project you want to create so it is
going to create the basic skeleton for
any spring application automatically for
you it's probably like I said it's
probably the fastest way to get started
with spring so we will choose a maven
project Maven is again a dependency
management tool which is used to
download any kind of jars for your
application so we are going to use a
maven project and we want to create a
skeleton for a Java application we are
going to use the latest released version
of spring or spring boot which is 2.4.2
it says spring boot here but don't get
confused with it we are going to use
just the MVC classes and not the spring
boot specific logic yet then you provide
your group artifact ID and the name for
your jar you provide a description you
can provide a welcome package name
whatever suits you and then how you
would like to run your application
whether you would like to package your
application as a jar file which is a
Java archive or you would like to run it
as a web archive 5 which is a war file
so you can choose either packaging mode
and it is going to add appropriate
dependencies inside the project to
support the packaging of Jar or the
packaging of four then you can also
choose a Java version so you can see
there are three Java versions listed
here which are 8 11 and 15 so whichever
Java version you are working on you can
choose that particular version and once
you have set all with everything just
hit generate once you do that it is
going to create a project here and then
you can import this project just as a
normal project inside the Eclipse IDE
and that's exactly what I've done for
this initial project which is showing a
very basic hello world sort of example
for how spring MVC will work so this
whole structure will automatically be
created for you and like I said it was a
maven project and in every Maven project
you will have a pom.xml if I double
click on this it is going to open this
XML and it will list down all the
dependencies which my project needs to
have let's understand the dependencies
as well so this project is currently
using the properties of 1.8 but that's
and that's fine you can obviously
definitely change this value I just kept
it as 1.8 for now because I'm not using
any new functionality yet in the
dependencies section you will see all
the dependencies or all the jars which
are required by the spring application
to run successfully the first dependency
we see here is about die my leaf and
Diamond Leaf basically is a view
technology similar to GSP or similar to
servlets uh technically where you can
supply use this diamai Leaf templates
which are basically just htmls with some
Dynamic values and you can use this
dimylif templates to render web pages
for your spring MVC application if you
want to use some other view technology
you need to include the dependency of
that view technology here instead of die
my life so that's about that then you
need to include the spring boot starter
web the spring boot starter web is going
to enable your application to become a
web application then this is this is a
this is basically a good to have
dependency which you can have in your
project which will help you deploy the
project at runtime automatically without
restarting the server because the web
application will be running on a server
on a web server basically or an
application server technically because
it needs to run somewhere so that it's
where the clients can access it that's
how a web client architecture works or
the server client architecture works so
this dependency will allow you to deploy
changes dynamically at runtime without
restarting the server then this
dependency is for tests if you're
writing any unit tests and then you have
a plugin which will allow to run this
particular project with a single command
which we will see in a while so that's
about the dependency tour now let's look
at what is in the SRC main Java in the
SRC main Java I just have two classes
one is the main class which will have a
public static void main method and this
is the entry point of this spring
application and then I have a controller
class I already talked about what
controller is but I will come back to
that in a while let's understand the
rest of the files as well the next one
is SRC main resources where you will
have your view technology data available
like I mentioned it is using diamai Leaf
templates currently and basically like I
said they are technically htmls with
some Dynamic data so I've created a
templates folder under SRC main
resources which will automatically be
generated by Spring initializer and then
under templates I have placed an HTML
file it's a pure HTML file with the only
difference is this value so this is what
the dynamic value means which which is
supported by Dima Leaf templates
otherwise this is pure HTML it's just a
paragraph with a header and this is the
dynamic value which I am populating it
also has application.properties which
has nothing but you can use this
particular file to supply environment
specific properties for the development
environment or the testing environment
or the real production environment if
you have any unit tests those will go
here under SRC test Java and this is the
system Library already provided
supported by Eclipse itself and I
already talked about the palm.xml you
also see couple of more files created by
springboot if you want to use that you
can use that to run the run the program
from the command line as a utility
otherwise you can just use mvn spring
boot command which I will show you in a
while there's also a Gradle folder which
you can ignore probably we don't need
this because we are just using Maven and
we are not using Gradle griddle is
another dependency management tool very
very similar to Maven so you can ignore
this folder right now so that's the
structure and now let's come back to the
controllers remember I told you that
controllers are the ones which receive
the request so from the dispatcher
servlet which I talked about here after
the dispatcher servlet the request comes
to the controller so once you hit a
particular URL then you need to create a
controller for that URL mapping remember
that you need to create a controller for
almost every URL mapping you are having
in your application there should be some
mapping to some controller somewhere so
I've created a greeting controller and
the way you specify or you make a simple
class as a controller is by putting the
add the red controller annotation this
is The annotation which is supported by
Spring and you can put this annotation
on top of any class and that class will
be treated as controller by Spring and
the moment the moment you put this this
class will also be registered with the
dispatcher servlet and like I mentioned
the controller's main purpose is to
receive the requests the web requests
which are coming from the client and the
way you can receive the requests to a
controller by providing the exact URL
mapping so if somebody runs this web
application and says slash greeting then
this particular method should get
invoked and how you define that is with
the get mapping annotation use the get
mapping annotation to provide the URL
path whenever some body invokes this URL
path this method would be getting called
and when this method is getting called
at that same time this URL can also
accept some query parameters we call
that as request parameters in in the
spring language so you can use the
request parameters as an annotation to
provide a placeholder for the variable
for which the value will be supplied in
the URL so slash greeting if if you call
this URL something like this then it
will work because you have a variable
called name which is which is being
parsed as a query string because you
have used the request param annotation
so we'll see the example of that when
once we run this application and how we
can supply the query string but you use
the request param annotation to supply
the query string parameters to the URL
you can mention if the parameter is
mandatory or non-mandatory if the
required equal to True was there then
this parameter would be mandatory you
can also Supply a default value if
somebody is if the client is not
providing this query parameter at all
would you like to set any default value
if yes you can supply the default value
here and then you just give a
placeholder name like I said then the
second argument which your your methods
which are intercepting the request
should have is the model argument and
right remember I told you that the
controller will have or should have the
knowledge about the model and from here
then that knowledge comes you this
particular method will expect you to
provide a model argument as well so if
somebody calls this application and
provides the URLs with Slash greeting
this particular method will get invoked
and then the code inside this method
will be getting executed so it's a very
simple code right now but this is where
your whole logic will go remember that
but here I'm just saying model dot add
attribute name with the value which is
coming from the query string parameter
that's all I'm doing here and remember I
told you that the model will hold the
business logic so here this is the
business this logic where whatever query
string parameter which is coming from
the request param I'm capturing that and
I am adding that value with the variable
name in the attributes of the model so
my model is set and after that I need to
return the view so that this particular
file name will be intercepted by The
View resolver here if you remember we
talked about the view resolver so when
we return greetings as a string that
string goes here and then dispatcher
servlet looks out asks the view resolver
to find a particular HTML matching with
this particular text so view resolver is
going to look at under SRC main
resources slash templates to see if
there is a file with the name greeting
available or not since we have that file
available the spring is going to render
this particular file supplying the model
attribute value name now remember the
greeting.html had the exact same
variable name so this variable name
should exactly match with this variable
name here if you do if you make a
mistake here this is not going to work
because the model is holding the
business logic and I'm printing that
business logic inside The View using the
die my lift template syntax which is
dollar curly braces so whenever you have
to print any variable or a model
attribute or any runtime value inside a
thermal if template then you need to use
the dollar curly braces syntax to do
that so that was about a quick overview
of how this application is is written
right now and that's all the code is
here now it's time to run this
application so one of the simplest way
to run this application would be to
provide a spring com run configuration
here for the spring application or you
can choose another way which is to First
have a look at the spring web content
application which is the entry point so
once your application boots up this is
the first line of code which is going to
get executed and to make sure that this
code Works make sure that you have the
add the red spring boot application
annotation on top of the entry point
class so this is this is sort of the
Mandate which spring will force you to
put in front of the or on top of the
entry point class to to treat this class
as the first entry point when you run
the project so to run the project what
we will do that we will just go to the
command line and we will say mvn spring
boot run so let's do that and let me
open the terminal for that so I have
opened a git bash prompt here you can
also open the classic Windows terminal
but this is something which git installs
by default if you install git on your
system it's pretty much exactly the same
it's just more Unix like but it's also
just a simple terminal shell utility to
access your file system so I have gone
to the project which we were working
with in the Eclipse IDE and this is the
path of the project so once you reach to
the path what you would like to run is
just say mvn spring hyphen boot colon
run that's it and you hit enter once you
write mvn spring hyphen boot colon run
you will see lot of code lot of logs
here where it is going to run all the
compile all the Java classes run any
tests if there are any and then it is
going to start the web content
application you can see and once the
application is started you will get this
message that everything is run one of
the interesting thing which you can see
here is that it is also spinning up an
application server automatically for you
and that application server here which
is being used by Spring is Apache Tomcat
technically Apache Tomcat is a servlet
container and it's not a full-fledged
application server but just to get the
point across you can use Apache Tomcat
as an application server which is being
used here at out of the box by Spring if
you don't want to use Apache tomcat and
you want to use something else you can
do that as well so now everything is
ready and we can now execute the
application to observe the output so for
that let me open a fresh browser window
so that we don't get any cast response
and now I can just type localhost 8080
and if I hit entry enter I I get a white
level error page because there is no
home page for Tomcat defined but there
is a home page for my application
defined in fact let's try to access the
URL which we wrote in the greeting
controller the URL was Slash greeting so
let's copy this and let's put this here
so localhost 8080 slash greeting and if
I hit enter I get the message hello
world let me just zoom this in a bit so
that you can see so you will see this
hello world message here by putting this
URL why do we see hello world let's go
back to the controller so when you call
this URL this greeting controller got
invoked since we did not provide any
query string parameter the default value
which was world was picked up and this
world value was stored in the name
variable and the name variable was added
as an attribute to the model and then we
were using the greeting.html and we were
printing the name variable since the
name variable was holding the Value
World so the message came as hello world
with an exclamation and that's the
output which we see here now let's try
to supply the queries query string
parameter the way you do that is provide
a question mark provide the key of the
query string parameter and the value you
want to put here so let's put simply
code as a value and hit enter so now the
message got changed and now it says
hello simply code so what happened here
is that whatever query string parameter
we supplied that got passed here at par
as part of the request param and the
value of Simply code got stored in this
name key and in turn in this name
variable and and then I added the same
value into another name attribute and
added that attribute to the model so now
this name here is storing the value
simply code and then the all the things
work exactly is the same as I just
described it goes to greeting.html and
it prints whatever is stored in the name
attribute coming from the model let's
get started with spring Boot and how we
can build a simple application using
spring boot before we go further let's
understand why we need spring Boot and
the basic idea of spring boot is to
build restful web services if you want
to know more about what are restful
services please you can read about the
restful concept as a concept what does
rest stand for but the basic idea is
that if you are accessing anything over
HTTP then that particular component can
be built as a restful component and
spring boot is the most popular choice
for building restful web services today
and even in fact micro Services which
you might have heard about so you can
build microservices which also run on
https using spring boot so what I'm
showing you right now is the official
guide of spring which you can use to
build an application with spring boot it
will list down all the requisites which
you need in terms of the jdk
installations Maven on and how to
complete this guide etc etc you can
again use the same spring initializer
which I talked about in the previous
session you can use this to generate a
spring boot project for you specifically
so all those options are available here
so I have already done that and I'm not
going to repeat what I just did in the
previous session and will directly jump
to an IDE where I have created a sample
spring boot application and the
structure here you can see the structure
would look very similar with one change
that in the previous example when we
were dealing with MVC we had an SRC main
resources folder and that SRC main
resources folder was having all the the
web components or the htmls but since in
restful web services you do not render
the HTML but you just send back the
response the response can be the
response body can be pure XML or it can
be pure Json but you do not send back
and View and that's the main difference
between spring MVC and spring boot that
in Spring MVC it will you are required
to return a view technology like in the
in the previous session we sent a die my
lift template which is basically in HTML
you can also written a GSP but with
spring boot you do not deal with the
view technology and that's the world we
are living in today when you write
spring boot you do not have to worry
about how this is going to be rendered
on the web page whether it is going to
be rendered using HTML or what not what
you need to take care of using spring
boot is to return the right response
body the exact text of the response and
that's it so with that in mind the
springboard was born and the structure
apart from that the structure would look
very similar there's a palm.xml here
which will provide all the list of jars
and dependencies which are required for
this particular project so you can see
all the dependencies here pretty much
the similar ones we have a starter web
we have a starters test and we have a
spring boot Maven plugin and we have an
application file which is the entry
point again having a public static void
main method so you need to put the at
the red spring boot application at the
top of the class to make it an entry
point if you don't do this spring boot
will not run this class and spring boot
will even not run your application so
what we are doing as part of this
example that we are just printing all
the beans which are provided by Spring
that's all we are doing like I said it's
a very lightweight and introductory
session so we will keep the Logics to
minimum and I'm just getting all the
beam definitions sorting the beam
definitions and just printing them one
by one how do we get the bean definition
you get that with this apple application
context class which is returned when you
run the application and how you run the
application is basically using this line
where you say spring application dot run
and you supply application.class with
any command line arguments which you
might want to use once you do this it is
going to return an application context
object to you and the application
context object can be used to get all
the bean definitions by calling this
method which says get bean definition
names so that's the basic logic which is
being run in the main class now we also
have a controller but this time it's not
a web controller but it's a rest
controller so you see in the previous
example we just had written something
like this it was just a pure controller
but here we have become more specific we
are saying that hey this is not a simple
MVC controller but this is a spring boot
controller or technically a rest
controller so spring provides a separate
annotation for that which is at the rate
rest controller so you write that
particular annotation or that on the top
of the controller class which you are
creating and then you provide a request
mapping similar to what we did in Spring
MVC but while you return it you do not
return a view technology you just return
the raw response here I'm just returning
a string but you can return a Json
object you can return an XML object or
whatever you want to but not a view
technology that's what I'm doing like
like you can see there's literally
nothing I'm doing in this it's just a
simple string return statement which I
have printed here and that's all the
code I have right now here I just have
these two classes okay so that was all
about what I have written in the project
and now it's time to run the project so
I have just reached to the location on
inside my terminal where the projects
palm.xml was present and if I just do an
LS you will see that there is a palm.xml
available here and all the code
directory is also available here so now
I will just run this application and to
run this application I'm just going to
type mvn Spring High different boot
colon run and hit enter once I do that
the spring application is going to
Spring boot application is going to get
started and let's go back to the
controller and actually the main app
main endpoint and see what we were doing
there I did a Swiss out here which said
let's inspect the beans provided by
Spring Boot and then I was printing all
the beam names and if I go back to the
output I will see the same line being
written here which was around let's
inspect the beans so you can see that
message which says let's inspect the
beans provided by Spring Boot and then
all the beans which are available in the
application context are printed here so
that's that's the basic idea which I
want to give you that you can actually
build a spring boot application and you
can write your rest controllers return a
string body from it and once this is run
then you can also run your application
for from the web browser as well so
let's try to hit that particular you URL
which I wrote here so the URL of hello
so for that let me just open a new
Cognito window and our application is
already running so if I just say HTTP
localhost 8080 slash I get this message
here which says greetings from Spring
Boot and this is the message which we
were sending from the rest controller so
this validates our understanding that we
can invoke a rest controller which is a
spring boot rest controller via the same
method but this time we are not getting
an HTML but we are just returning this
particular string now you can use the
string in any ways you want so it
depends upon the consumer so that's all
I want to cover uh as part of the spring
boot now spring boot is a huge huge
topic and we can spend hours and hours
talking about spring boot but since this
is more of an introductory session so I
just wanted the concept to get
introduced and remember the value
proposition of why you would need spring
boot the basic idea is to build restful
website services or build restful
microservices that's the basic idea
behind using spring boot in your
applications and also remember the
difference between webmvc apply spring
MVC application and spring boot
application spring MVC is for building
web application spring boot is for
building restful applications which
might not have a web interface
integrated with them at that moment so
that's all I want to cover for this
particular session and in the next
session we are going to have a look at
an advanced Java project using some of
the concepts which we might have learned
during this whole journey and that would
be the last session of this particular
tutorial series let's get started with
our demo of a project which is using
spring boot to build a restful web
service so a restful web service is
nothing but any endpoint which you can
access or you can consume the data from
via an HTTP layer or via a simply a web
layer because most of the web traffic
which we deal with is built on HTTP so
to take an example if you go to any
website where you sometimes see on the
top right corner you see today's weather
so how is that today's weather coming in
it's coming in Via our rest web service
the website which you are accessing is
basically hitting an HTTP endpoint which
is uh where the where the weather
application is sitting and it asks for
the weather data and the rest web
application just Returns the data and
that's how the website is able to show
you the current weather so restful web
services are everywhere and they are the
most popular way to build applications
today where you just build your restful
web service and you expose in HTTP URL
and then the consumers need to just
access that HTTP URL to consume the data
from your application and you see this
makes it very easy because there is no
data type restrictions there is no tight
coupling here it's just an HTTP endpoint
so that's the basic idea and we will
look at a project where we will be using
spring boot to build a restful website
service and then we will try to run that
web service to save some data and also
to return some data so here on the on
the package Explorer you see I have
created a project called rest service
and let's just walk through the
structure of it and then we'll go into
the details of it so we have an SRC main
Java where I have a package and I have
bunch of classes here and before we go
to the classes let's first also access
the dependency file because every
project needs some dependencies some
jars to execute it for example spring
itself is basically a jar so you need to
include the spring jar in your project
so that your project can become a spring
project and there are generally two
dependency tools one is Maven and one is
Gradle in this particular project I am
using Maven dependency tool for
downloading and managing the
dependencies which are needed to run
this project successfully and the way
you will find if it's a maven project or
if it's a Gradle project for a maven
project you will see a file called
pom.xml.com
and if it's a Gradle project you will
see a DOT griddle file that's how you
can spot whether the project is using
Maven for dependency management or it is
using Gradle for dependency management
so let's open the palm.xml since it's an
XML file it will be a bit verbose but if
you just read it piece by piece it will
become easier to understand first of all
since this is a spring project I need to
include the parent dependency which
brings lot of good defaults sensible
defaults from Spring boot automatically
and this is the jar name this is the
artifact ID which is spring boot starter
parent so any spring boot project you
are starting do include this parent this
parent is basically bringing all the
dependencies from some other jar and you
can make your project as a as a child of
this particular parent so all the spring
boot projects have this as a parent as a
standard practice after that you provide
your own details in terms of what is the
package name how do you want to see the
jar name on what is the jar actual name
what is the jar version etc etc you also
send the minimum required Java version
to run this application and then you in
the dependency sections you provide all
the jars which you need to run your
project successfully both compile and
run your project successfully so we
added the spring boot starter web on
dependency which basically brings all
the dependencies around making a
controller or making a repository count
the context component scan all the
interesting features which spring
provides get wrapped up inside the
spring boot starter jar and you can
actually go to the mvn repository and
and have a look at what all classes it
provides it's a lot of classes so I'm
just telling you in a brief that it
provides all the restful functionality
then you have the next dependency as
spring boot starter data jpa which is
going to enable this project to also
have a database and if it has a database
then you need Java to talk to the
database and the Way Spring suggests to
talk to the database is via using the
springboot data JPI Library we will see
this how this Library can be used but
basically this provides ways to
represent your Java object in the
database and then you need to also add
the actual dependency of the database
and in this case we are using an
in-memory H2 database so I'm not using
an external database like MySQL or
Oracle or post SQL because that will
just make more configurations more
complicated I just wanted to keep it
simple and generally you in this H2
database you can easily access by adding
this dependency and it will be an
in-memory database created for you then
I've also added a spring boot starter
test here which will be used whenever
you are writing unit tests and you must
write unit test for your project and
then we need to add the plugin so that
spring boot can run this project that's
all I have in the palm.xml now let's
move to the interesting part the Java
section part let's start from the main
class so this is how the main class
looks like where you have you just
create uh any any name with the class
and then you add a public static void
main method and inside the public static
white main method you call Spring
application dot run and this run method
is basically going to run your
application and you just provide the
same class name which you just wrote
here so you just say dot class and if
you're supplying any command line
arguments it can interpret that command
line arguments as well if you want so
you would always need an entry point in
an application and this is the entry
point which springboot supports and this
is if you see this code this is just
normal code to make spring be aware
about this class being treated as an
entry point you need to add add the red
spring boot application annotation on
top of the class this is one of The
annotation which is coming directly from
the spring boot Library you can see this
import so once you add this then only
spring will be able to treat this class
as an entry point otherwise spring
doesn't know where to start from so when
you run spring it will fi it will try to
find a class with an annotation spring
boot application and then inside the
class it will try to find a public
storage a static void main method and
once it has found both of them then it
will just run the application so it's
very simple nothing fancy here and what
we are dealing with here is a student
object so we will try to insert the
student object and we will try to
retrieve the student object so if you
ignore these annotations which I've
added it's just a pure pojo it's just a
plain old Java object you create a
student class Let's ignore this field as
well for now I'll just come back to this
annotation in this field but this is
just a student class it has three Fields
as name age and address an empty
Constructor and a parameterized
Constructor and some Getters
intentionally I have removed the Setters
because generally whenever you are
building any Enterprise grade
application you would like to keep your
objects immutable means once they have
been created you would not like somebody
to allow to change the values of the
object this just makes programming much
much more easy if you treat all the
objects in your application as immutable
that's why I I have not added Setters
here it's just considered a good
practice so apart from the standard
things which we have already seen there
are two things here which I want to talk
about let's first talk about this one so
at the rate entity is The annotation
which is coming from java X persistent
entity persistence entity and this makes
spring boot save this particular object
into the database this is The annotation
which you need to put on your class so
that springboot knows that this class
represents a table in the database so
you need to add this to make sure that
this represents a table second thing a
table will have a ID it will have sort
of a primary key so I've created a new
column called ID which is basically
representing the student's row number or
something or maybe a registration number
and here I'm using couple of more
annotations if you see these annotations
are also coming from java X persistence
library and these annotations will
basically allow the a new ID to be
created every time you create a student
object so you don't have to specify the
value of this ID variable springboot
will automatically generate a new ID
value every time you create a new
student object and how does it generate
you you can provide the generation type
as well so currently I've just set that
set it as automatic but you can set it
as identity sequence or return or
control by table you can also see the
explanation of each of these here but
I've just kept it as Auto which
basically uh let the persistence
provider pick any appropriate strategy
for the particular database in our case
the database is H2 so that's about the
entity class let's call this as entity
class now let's move to the repository
so you need a repository class like I
explained in those in that three tier
architecture you always need a dow layer
or a repository layer to store your
student object into the database so we
have enabled the student object to be
saved but we need a Handler which can
save this particular file this
particular object into the database and
the repository classes are the classes
which will allow you to do that effect
so you create a very simple interface
you what you name whatever you want to
name your interface as and then you say
extends jpa repository the type of the
object and the unique identifier of the
object so the type of the object is
student here and the unique identifier
of the student object is the ID which is
of type long so you need to just Supply
the types type of the object type of the
primary key or the type of the unique
identifier and this annotation is coming
from Spring boot you can see
specifically spring boot data Library
which we added so you just need to
create an interface extend it from JP
repository and make sure that you add
this annotation as well spring heavily
uses the concept of annotations and this
will help spring understand that this is
a repository layer class and it will
apply some more metadata to this class
while this class is running in the jvm
so what happens here we just created an
interface it did not provide any method
to create or any method to delete or any
method to get a a student object because
all of that is automatically provided by
springboot via the jpa repository class
if we go inside this class and if you
scroll down you will see the find all
method find all find all by ID save all
flash save and Flash delete
Etc and if you go further up this also
extends the paging and sorting
repository which provides pagination and
sorting facilities but the interesting
one is that paging and sorting
repository again extends a curled
repository and if you go to the credit
repository you will find all the basic
methods to save an entity save multiple
entities find an entity by the ID that's
why it needed that long type to make
sure this that it can execute this
method you can check the existence of an
object find all the entries find all by
ID count them delete them so all the
basic crud functionality so we call them
as crud because the reason it is called
crude because create read update delete
that's the basically the generic acronym
so because this credit repository
provides all the methods and their
implementations automatically we do not
need to write any code at all so that's
why spring boot is so awesome and that's
why springboard is very popular because
it's zero code in the repository and you
still get all the current functionality
so that's about repository now we have
covered the entity class we have covered
the repository class we have covered the
entry point class now the only thing
which is remaining is the is the end
point the HTTP endpoint which I talked
about and that you can create by
creating any class generally try to
suffix it with the controller so that
your co-developers can easily find this
class and make sure that you put at the
red rest controller annotation on top of
it this annotation will allow spring to
read this particular class as an
endpoint class then you can Auto wire
the student repository so if you
remember I talked about the whole
dependency injection and inversion of
control so here dependency injection is
in action so here you are just telling
student controller to Auto wire the
student repository and now what will
happen that at runtime student
controller or actually spring will
automatically create an object of the
student repository and Supply that
object of student repository to student
controller so you as developer do not
have to create an object of student
repository explicitly that's the benefit
and that's how the dependency injection
is working because you inverted the
dependencies now the dependency is just
injected into the class and as a
developer you don't have to take control
of creating the objects is the spring
which will automatically read the Auto
World annotation and will automatically
Supply an object whenever it is required
then I have two methods here since we
are talking about HTTP endpoints so I
have represented a post method here and
a get method here the way you will write
a post method is via at the rate post
mapping annotation and then you can
provide the URL path on which somebody
should call your endpoint to save
something so for example example
somebody can call it HTTP localhost 8080
slash student slash create whenever they
hit that URL the control or that request
will directly hit this particular method
why because you have provided the URL
mapping here in the post mapping
annotation so since it's a post method
there would be request body what is the
actual request body which the client is
sending and you can represent that
request body with the add direct request
body annotation and you can provide the
type of the request body and here I'm
saying that hey if you want to access
this particular URL yes all good but you
need to supply me with a text
representation of the student object or
a Json representation of the student
object and then I inside the method I'm
calling student repository dot Save
which is going to save the student
object which is coming in so you see
this lot going on here I will I will
show you how the student is represented
in the request body as well and then I
will come back to how it got converted
from Json to to Java but this is how you
can store this particular student object
you can hit this API as many times as
you want and keep inserting a new
student object every time then if you
want to fetch a particular student then
you can do that by supplying the slash
student and then in the curly braces
there's an ID written here so basically
you can supply the value of the ID of
the student so generally there would be
another method here which would be find
all to see all the students and with
their ID and then you can pick a
particular students ID Supply that
student ID value here dynamically that's
why the curly braces curly braces
supports Dynamic value so here it can
insert One Two Three or whatever the
student ID you want to fetch the value
for you provide that value in the
student slash ID and all good then some
if somebody is getting the URL with
saying localhost 8080 slash student
slash one then student with the ID 1
will be returned from the request and
you need to put advert get mapping to
make sure that this method is treated as
an HTTP get method and you can can
provide the type you can set say get
student and here this Dynamic value is
captured with the at the rate path
variable because you need to know the ID
right whatever ID somebody has supplied
it in the URL you need to capture that
IDE and then use that IDE for calling
the repository so that's you can do that
by using the add the red path variable
so here I'm just saying whatever ID is
coming in I will store that value inside
this IDE once I've done that then I can
again call student repository dot find
by ID which is again a built-in method
provided to me by the credit repository
I can supply the ID and this actually is
going to return an optional object which
is uh which is an object which may or
may not contain a value so it's a just a
types a defensive programming style so
this will return an optional and you can
call a get method to return the actual
student object this will return an
optional of student so option of student
means that this optional object may have
a student or may not have a student why
did spring do that that because the ID
somebody is supplying that ID can be
invalid also right so optional object
tree and takes care of that that if
there is no student found then you will
not get a null pointer exception and if
there's a student found you can return
that so it's just a defensive
programming style which spring has
adopted by returning an optional of the
student object rather than directly the
student object but if you are confident
that this particular option of student
object does contain a student object
then just call optional.get which I've
called here which will return the actual
student object sitting inside the
optional object you can read more about
the optional object and its usage from
the official Java docs and there are
tons of examples available on it on
internet so this is about the controller
we have covered all the classes now it's
time to run the application so you go to
the command prompt you go to the
particular file folder location and
there you just say mvn spring hyphen
boot colon run so I just hit enter and
this is going to run the application
it's going to split some logs here and
if everything is fine you will not get
an error and you will just be getting a
message saying that application got
started and it's running on Tomcat
localhost 8080 with no context URL so
this is not a web application this is a
restful web service right this is a
restful service this is not a web
application so there is no web interface
so how do you access this you just have
an HTTP URL so you can use any of the
rest client available on the internet
there are probably hundreds of different
rest clients available on the internet
you can choose any one of them I am
using Advanced rest client which you can
also install as an extension from the
Chrome browser itself so if you just if
I just open the Chrome browser and I
just say pressed client if you just
write this and hit enter you will get
many different options and the first
option you get is from Google Play
Store's App Store so you can go to the
App Store that basically the Chrome web
store not the play store but the Chrome
web store and you can just install this
since this is already installed you can
click on launch app and it will open
this interface for you so this is pretty
uh this is not a tutorial for advanced
rest clients so I'll just be quick here
you can choose the method type which you
want to hit so let's say I want to do a
post and then you can provide the URL
here so remember the URL which we put
here in the controller method this has
to exactly match so HTTP localhost slash
student slash create should be the URL
so let me just copy paste this one here
okay so the URL is good here it's a post
type of method which I want to do and I
want to hit this particular URL now I
need to supply the content type and the
body so in the content type you can
choose application Json because I'm
going to supply a Json object and in the
body this is how the Json object looks
like Advanced rest client also provides
a nice visual interface to basically
create this Json if you are thinking
that Json creation is very tough it's
not actually tough It's just curly
braces and then you put key and value
key value comma let me just and enter
here so that it's more readable so you
just put curly braces starting in end
and then you just put key value you put
a key which is the variable name and the
variables value variable name variable
value and these Keys have to exactly
match the students properties so the
student.java had this name page and
address right so it has to exactly match
otherwise this will request will fail so
this is all good now I can send this
particular request when you click Send
it is going to hit my spring boot
application which is running on
localhost 8080 it is going to call the
student slash create method it is also
going to convert this Json into a Java
object because here I am supplying a
Java object so it will convert the Json
which I'm sending from here to Java
object automatically and it is going to
automatically save it here because I've
called the repository.save method so
let's hit send here once I hit send I
get a 200 okay it means everything went
fine and in the response header I get
the object back because I have returned
the object here you see this save method
is going to return the same student
object which you created uh so
everything is good here my object has
been stored here and now it's time to
fetch the object so it has already been
saved in the into the H2 in memory
database and you can obviously go and
connect to the in-memory H2 database and
have a look at it but for Simplicity I'm
just gonna do this here and let's say
the first object is generally added as
the id1 by default by the H2 database so
let's hit this particular URL when I hit
this URL it is going to hit the student
controller here and in the student
controller it is going to hit the get
student method which is having a student
slash ID URL and it is going to find the
database with that ID and if it finds a
student object with that ID it is going
to return that so let's confirm that now
let's hit this particular send button
and it is going to hit a get request
with this particular URL string button
is going to find if a student with the
id1 exists in its database so once I hit
send I get a 200 okay and you see in the
response headers I get the same student
object back which I added let's try with
two now let's see what happens I see two
and I get 500 internal server error
because there is no object stored in the
H2 database of the spring application
with the id2 yet because we only
inserted one object that's why only one
student object is there and the first ID
which H2 database created for it
automatically was one so when you hit
for get request with a student id1 you
get the object when you put any invalid
value and you hit this you get a 500
internal server error you can also make
it look nice by not sending the 500
internal server error and sending a nice
exception from the back end so from here
you can also send a nice exception that
if this object is not found you can say
something like that or else throw which
is again an optional object and here
here you can supply a particular type of
exception which you want to supply
instead of just throwing 500 internal
server error but that's just additional
thing additional defensive programming
you can do you can add more and more
validation and constraints into this
project as you build this project in a
more complex Paradigm so this is
basically what I wanted to show you that
and that we have created a springer boot
application we have connected it to a
database we haven't created also an HTTP
endpoint with student controller we ran
that application we used any random rest
client in my case I used Advanced stress
client and we first did a post request
we provided the exact URL the URL has to
exactly match with the controller URL
and then the body the request body also
has to exactly match with the student
objects property especially the case of
the names have to exactly match so if
this all this matches then you will get
a response back that the object has been
created if you want to fetch the value
of the object you are going to use the
HTTP get method and you again provide
URL which has to exactly match to some
method in some controller in the spring
boot application which is running on
localhost and if you provide the right
ID you are going to return get a valid
result if you provide an invalid ID
you're going to get a 500 internal
server error and from here on you can
make this controller as robust and as
mature as you want you can add find all
methods you can add update student
method you can add a delete student
method you can have all different kinds
of filters let for example return to me
all the students starting with the name
a or return all the first students with
the rule number one and 100 or between
100 so you can write as many endpoints
as you want and build this application
in as with as much maturity and as much
complexity as you want and that's all I
want to cover in this particular lecture
thank you and we'll meet again in
another session and with that we have
come to an end of day 5 of software
development I hope this session was
informative and interesting
on day six of software development we
will explore a whole new and Powerful
programming language that has the
potential to take a head-on-head
competition with Java and a simple and
easy to learn at the same time yes you
guessed it right the python until next
time thanks for watching don't forget to
subscribe to stay tuned for more from
Centrelink
foreign
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here